Ethan great move hello everybody it is I
Ethan Klein with a haircut and I'm
wearing pants as
well who is
he it's a new year a new year welcome
Ela nice to see you lovely to have you
it's Friday baby yep hope you guys all
had a good week and we'll have a great
weekend ahead and let's just get it
started let's just jump into it right
now you know what I'm
saying thank you to hexclad for
sponsoring this uh episode thank you as
well as Teddy fresh who uh the CEO is
actually sitting beside me the principal
designer CEO creative
lead hiloc
Cline sometimes I started to say
hila cuz I feel like it's people
understand it a lot easier I know I know
know what you mean heila like a heil
monster what are those called
but big ass lizard Gila Gila monster I
like it better with The Silent Age Ela
yeah but I know what you mean sometimes
I don't know how to say it myself when
people ask me what's my name yeah cuz
I'm just like h l for some reason the
ELA is like I think it's because I
shouldn't have spelled it like that
technically but even if you don't see
the spelling I don't know at least for
me when I first heard it I was like what
like what I don't understand what what's
happening there at the beginning yeah
anyway here's Teddy fresh.com we got the
here you want to you want to break it
down so here we have this set where the
teddy bear and the splotches are made
with bleach and so it's almost like a
stencil and then they poured bleach so
they all feel a little different and
kind of like not perfect and then here
we wanted to just throw a bunch of teddy
bear patches on everything on the hat
and on the
set love it that's what I'm wearing
today this is the lavender
color and here we have the beaded bag
which is so
cute it's Beed it's made of beads it's
beaded y'all and then we made it big
enough so you can actually fit you know
at least like phone wallet keys
Essentials big yeah big
enough cute and and there's a necklace I
believe I don't know if you showed yeah
I'm going not yet not yet here it is yes
is there a closeup of it or is that
that's not here we have it on Instagram
there you go I'm wearing that today oh I
got to say I always say this the teddy
fresh jewelry oh nice cam the teddy
fresh jewelry ni is always so good thank
you it is every time
good um and it always people I think
people love the jewelry too it always
does really well and it always looks
great you
know here it is yeah it's the
uh oh and this t-shirt also it's um so
we took a bunch of little charms and
bows and we scanned them and made a
little print out of it I think it's so
cute there it is and we're
scrolling we're
scrolling we're scrolling and we're done
Teddy fresh.com thank you this is all
out today right
now so uh wow there's just so much to do
today you know it's so much to get to so
much to talk about today I today I feel
go on say it today I feel uh gay
why cuz I got a
haircut I got to say I love the sides M
the top is too long I look like a oong
shaped hot dog man like I just I don't
like the shape of my
head Oh what now it's just you know I
look like a [__] hot dog like have
you ever seen such a cylinder looking
head I like it
entering I like it too it's just too
long on the top don't you think I mean
that's what I do my hair is just uh
longer than yours but I think maybe
you're not used to it I don't know n it
looks weird what did you think Ela when
you first saw him don't act like you
didn't agree with me now so I will say I
think it looks very good but I just it's
just not
Ethan and I I kind of like the regular
Ethan
better maybe you're used to
that I think it would look good just a
little off the top that's cuz my top you
want to do it AB I trust you oh uh no
I'm good mine I did mine yesterday and
yeah I'm not really feeling it either I
think it just take some time to get used
to it doesn't look bad you faded
yourself out uh no my barber did oh nice
which I did have scheduled beforehand
just everyone knows not that I
wouldn't interesting timing
there you weren't outside my house today
were you I was not I actually did want
to clarify that uh from the last episode
me and Lena were out we heard about the
situation I went I don't want to say the
business but I went to the business near
house and I was waiting there and I
texted you guys everything good you went
to the what the business near your
guys's house the business in our house
near your house oh a b you went to a
business near our house yes okay um but
yeah and I was texting you guys saying
you're good should I could pull up I
don't mind and you guys are like no no
it's okay so I respected your guys this
what happened I know AB I know I'm I
love what he said when the Cody thing
was going down Jeff's friend who's now
my best friend by the way if you watched
I was on Jeff show yesterday I didn't
get to watch it we have really good
report me and Cody we're actually United
against Jeff
now I saw you guys were very silly
together he could he could bought me a
coke oh yeah Coke Zero okay mhm what a
guy cute he is really nice actually when
he's not threatening and stalking he's
super
nice um and he told me all about jail
cuz he's apparently like a Three Time
Felon wow nonviolent okay nonviolent
felon now expunction now expunction
course yeah so clean record him Jeff too
they both got expunged they can vote
everybody deserves a clean a clean start
I didn't know you could do that and then
well my question is after you get
expunged can you get expunged again cuz
it seems like a loophole is that the
word like sponge
expunged I actually don't know how it's
spelled but I know that's but um so I
didn't know that was brought up but I
remember
AB the conversation it was very nice of
you oh thank you so yeah yeah I kind of
made it seem like I was just outside the
house with binoculars I wasn't that
night maybe another night but not that
night um that was before you were hired
yeah before I tired but uh no I was just
uh I don't know it was just a weird
situation it was all happening so fast
yeah so I didn't know if it was one guy
or five guys not that I could have
really done anything I'd have to hit him
with the car but yeah appreciated that
it's nice to feel like there's
somebody with you you know it was like I
got you guys if you need he can come run
in distract him I'll leave yeah I'll
call the police you
know um I've got to defend myself a
little bit here I guess people are
saying oh Ethan doxing again okay it was
just a joke guys was just doing a silly
funny don't say this game pin on the
screen out
loudan
[Laughter]
[Music]
people 753
2730 I thought one of them would react
but then I just let it linger you have
to let it
linger and then people go I thought
Ethan was joking but he was deaf reading
it out loud I think saying fake numbers
would have stumped himself like come on
bro you think what I can't chew
bubblegum and walk at the same time
what level of functionality do you think
I have oh my
God I will continually be underestimated
by fans and foes
alike yeah so that I don't know if Ethan
knows his numbers to be
honest but it was fun I love Jeff Love
Cody love his whole team they had very
nice things to say they're they they
like what we do they're fans they're all
inspired it's cool lots of accolades to
you guys I love the origin story it's
all very cool whose origin story of this
friendship oh me and Jeff yeah it's
pretty wild it all started on this crazy
interview when he called in listen he's
he's a good guy he just got caught up in
the middle of some really [__] up
stuff and with friends that really
didn't look out for him you
know yeah yeah it was crazy though do
you remember like the views it was like
160,000 or something like that oh was it
it was holy [__] it was crazy dude
Frenemies was nuts that that
was that that was a phenomenon like I
don't even know 160,000 that's what I
remember poor
Jeff me but I'm pretty sure that that's
what it was poor I was watching live I
remember it that was in the library oh
my God God I've never sank into my chair
lower than I did when cuz I I was there
switching cuz we were still doing it in
the basement at the time and when that
whole thing was going on I was just like
oh my God this is so comfortable this is
so bad well he told me uh they they have
drops there of the okay Ethan and they
also have the
uh uh I don't know they were they had
drops of him uh struggling through that
okay yeah but um but um
bu house yesterday this is important to
get out go ahead you want to say
something I'm just wondering where is
duck duck he's right here oh okay okay
cool duckus
Maximus um I had a really fun adventure
yesterday
I had to cut off Jeff's podcast at three
to go do a feal
sample y it's so embarrassing like when
you go to the front I don't like saying
it I go I'm here to do a drop off
but then they get confused here to make
a deposit they get
confused they go oh you're dropping off
okay and then and then they think I've
like [__] at home and brought it and
then I go no I don't have it with me
need to provide a live sample yeah they
go oh it's called a fresh sample I was
like
gross so the first place I went to they
were like were like okay well here's
like 20 different pieces I wish I
brought it is it in the car no I took it
out [__] God I wish I had it I'd show
you guys no because she's like you need
to go home [__] and there and last time
I did it it was just one cup like a
urine sample type of cup and it was
disgusting but you just put it in one
cup you move on with your life
mhm this time they had me a
bag with five different cups
three of them have tiny little narrow
entrances I I am not kidding when I tell
you it's this
narrow okay you can imagine the that's
not okay well anyway she's like so you
need to go home [__] in all five of
these and then if you want to bring it
back like tomorrow you have to
refrigerate I says I'm not putting my
[__] in my refrigerator oh my God I'm
not doing it I don't give with the
food I don't care if it's you know
hermetically is that her
hermetic hermetically sealed with
[__] NASA technology is not going in
my refrigerator no you got to throw the
fridge out after that yeah
so so Lena was able to call and get cuz
last time I did it there and that's what
I thought I was doing and frankly just
to be totally honest with you guys I was
holding in I had the [__] and I was
holding in all day right you were
talking about holding it in in from the
day before already
because unlike most people I cannot
control when I
poop it just it's out of my control so
being able to know like I've got one
loaded up in the chamber one in the
cannon locked and loaded oh that's not
something that happens at every
opportunity for me this was a carefully
organized plan and so Lena was able to
call um you want you could take that
part
Lena I don't know how to explain it well
so just don't violate my hippo rights of
course of course so you went to the
other lab where you can do the stool
sample there yourself and you couldn't
find it though I don't know how to
explain this part because I I couldn't
figure out how to explain it to you like
in any other way I hate when this
happens when well anyway Lena called and
she got me a she got me a walk-in for
the okay and it was real close so I
raced over there and they're like you
have to be there before to 45 right or
3:45 345 it was 4:45 4:45 what the [__]
took so damn long I left at three you
know
mhm and um I go up to the second floor
and the instructions they gave Lena is
just on the second floor I says okay
well there's you know there's like eight
different offices there's Radiology
there's oncology there no sweet number
there are sweet numbers but they didn't
tell Lena the sweet number they just
said second floor [__] onor what they
were explaining is that the lab is just
on the second floor but okay well you
know the lab is in you know Los
Angeles you got to be more specific
you've been there before right I have
been there before but there's different
offices and I've done blood work in like
the oncology part so the first place I
went to was the oncology part and I says
hey um I don't know if this is the right
place but uh I need to uh sh here I need
to uh there's [__] all over the floor do
a drop
off and they're like you're you're are
you with um
UPS what are you dropping off what are
you dropping off I have to drop off a
stool sample then they recoil in [__]
and they go I don't think that was
us I said okay then I I get embarrassed
so I go okay let me go to Radiology cuz
I mean I know it's not them but I say I
say is there cuz I was running at a time
440 right now yeah oh God so I was like
listen I know it's probably not you guys
but I need to take a [__] in a [__]
thing and have people where would you
think I would do that and then they told
me to try
21 I go to T10 yeah they love [__] over
there and then I tell them and she's
like I don't know what you're she's I
don't know what you're talking about let
me go ask back in the back CU she went
asked in the back and they figured it
out and they brought me so they brought
me this same setup though like everyone
in the building knows you're there to
take a giant shot it's
disgusting also I just want to mention I
also called the representative there to
ask them like how I could give you
better directions and they kept
emphasizing just second floor and he
didn't know what else to tell it's not
that I promise you it's not that easy
you walk in and there's just there's
tons of
Department you know and then you asked
the receptionist and she also told you
she didn't know what you're talking
about At first she did but she's like
let me check in back at at the right at
the whatever the the office 210 the
infamous
210 I'm glad you ended up making it
though me too
yeah can you imagine having to do all
that like [__] at your house and it
wasn't close to my house either it's
like an hour drive drive with that in
the car it's like a bio weapon imagine
getting pulled over explain that one
getting in an accident you shut down the
whole [__] everywhere yeah
so they gave me the same thing with the
two urine size cups and then the three
tiny little test tubes that's not okay
and so what are you supposed to do what
are you supposed to do so let me tell
you for the big ones it's the same as
last time there's just like a you know
the the wood stick the doctor puts on
your tongue yeah goes ah so you have one
of those for scooping into the big one
which is fine there's there's a big hole
it's a big stick it's disgusting it's V
but it's logistically is okay okay but
then you get into these little test
tubes and what happens is you unscrew it
and connected to the top of the lid is a
tiny
spoon so you need to scoop it and
there's there's liquid in the tube and
they say fill to this line so you take a
little scoop of [__] and by the way it's
a tiny spoon so scooping with a tiny
spoon out of a [__] is not easy Tak some
prise effort yeah yeah you a photo of
the picture you took yesterday when you
texted us and you're like I'm in oh yeah
I told you I wanted Lena to know that I
made it to the bathroom with
everything moments before
disaster yeah here's the small ones and
it's the size of the small ring here
yeah do you see how small that is yeah
yeah
okay
so maybe I can find a photo of the try
to find phot of the stool sample with
the tiny spoon under the lid and so
there's a little liquid in it and it
says fill to this line yeah so you put a
little [__] in there vile and then you
know frankly and this is so disgusting
that they this is what happens but you
have to
like you know like like you're putting
cream cheese back in like extra cream
cheese you know you have to like slide
it on the wall there's no other way to
get it out is it this I think I found it
yeah it's basically basically that I
found this one looks more like a fork
mine had spikes for some reason on it
this it's a
spork it it's literally a little it's
like a tulip oh my God it was so
stupid there's no better way to do that
I feel like this is a refined design I
feel like they know what they're doing
with this that looks like someone cut it
in the back H those edges are not
workmanship that's a prison shank right
there so anyway I had to do three of
that's not okay and there's and the
thing is like you know somebody's going
to have to like in the lab they take it
out and do all but there's [__] all over
the top sh all over the floor there's
[__] all over the floor it is and is
probably the most disgusting thing I've
ever had to do in my life I think it was
yeah
imagine it took a while too just five
samples you're
scooping you got sticks you got tiny
spoons yeah and then you have a bucket
of [__] cuz you had to put a [__]
[__] catcher in the toilet [__] in it
take it out of the toilet and then Scoop
from the bathroom floor no bucket is
required and last time they gave I was
wondering okay I was wondering where the
main load was being kept bucket is it's
in the but so it's like the pesto thing
you remember what the pesto is in is
like that Jake do little do you really
want to tell me that I'm faking illness
you freak have you not seen my pesto
[__] oops exactly never let that
go so and then last time they gave me
like a big garbage bag for all the dirty
[__] this time they didn't do it I don't
know if they forgot so I dumped that
excess [__] in the toilet but you still
have like a garbage you still have like
a recepticle with [__] on the side all
over it yeah and a spoon with [__] all
over it yeah and so there's there was
like a relatively small trash can in the
bathroom that I was forced to smash it
down and there was nowhere else to put
it piece of [__] I wanted to be clean
and hygienic and do the right thing yeah
so I just put it face down and just
forced it down there yeah I guess I
guess get on
me yeah and then you have to do a walk
of shame I will go over there with like
a whole
[__] god collection of turds to the
lab to drop it
off they go oh you just put it there I
says on the counter they says no in the
sink
so I think the only thing worse if is if
the receptionist is like wait are you
Ethan
Klein I think to be honest with you the
receptionist may have known who I was oh
cuz there was a slight glimmer of
recognition they're professionals right
cuz they're in healthcare they but there
was a slight smile and recognition I
felt a glint when I walked up and I was
like here we go I to do a drop off a
sample got [__] on me she's like okay
you brought it with you I said no well
in a sense yes but uh it's inside of me
still oh then the the first place I went
to by the way they go
um they go uh we're not equipped for
that the one that was tell me you have
to do it at home she's like we don't
have the bathrooms equipped for that and
I was like okay whatever and so when she
was done explaining and give me
everything I said can I use the restroom
cuz I had to pee really bad and she's
like yeah but not for that
right sneak a [__] in their bathroom
after she told me not to I ran home real
quick come out of the bathroom here you
go I ran home they thought you were
going to trick them what stck okay he's
chewing it to it but for the record that
bathroom was definitely set up for it
like they had it was looked identical
how much set you need that well you're
not going to be set up at home either
whatever that means yeah I don't know
what means it's not set up for they just
didn't want you to do it yeah they they
like oh boy maybe if I looked nicer or
like less gross they would have been
like go ahead yeah like this guy you got
the fade I got the fade maybe that's why
I'm actually looking I might get the um
last time I did the turd sample they
gave me the results the next day morning
so I'm looking bag of turd I uh maybe
I'll get it during the show that would
be
exciting but it was five samples this
time so clearly
there's we're focusing in
mhm what's the title David Dober calls
out Jason Nash Ben Shapiro drops rap
song are we liking the David do are we
feeling the pull of that yeah we're
vibing on that
one I am I hate to say enjoying because
it is tragic uh truly but Jason's just
his
deterioration as a respectable human
being if he ever was that I mean don't
don't mince my words here
people um
and and then David's like
absolute lack of empathy and care for
his friend yeah who help was there with
him the way up yeah he was with him
you're supposed to take your homies with
you you know my whole here got hold make
it and the whole crew is here what's
that Drake
song Start bot started from the bottom
and we're here started from the bottom
and the whole crew here I need to Max
win all the nword are here probably
something like that
congratulations I completely agree with
you it makes no sense and like living
fat that's always been one of our
criticism of David it's like he's like
having everybody be there use them no
payment no payment no insurance what is
that No Sa
but the thing is you know of all the
people on the socalled Vlog Squad
everybody's trying to do their own thing
Jason he was his guy M you know
sry what is
that you finally are oh my God I mean
I've heard it two weeks but I I mean
it's Drake oh it is I'm sorry is that a
uh it's from the Anita Max Anita Max wi
Anita Max wi that's he was doing these
like
congratulations I'm sorry he's such a
freak with the gambling [__] it's funny
though that's the problem yeah he's this
this dude he's on stake selling gambling
and this [__] has the balls to
sell merch with a little I guess
Hispanic looking
woman Anita Max is that out of pocket
that's what it is no he does the accent
too and her name is Anita maxwin Anita
maxen he goes Anita maxen and he's
selling a hat oh my he's selling merch
now about his
gambling uh sponsorship this dude has a
layers of earnings yeah he's made like a
Persona of his gambling addiction it's
great I need a maxwe it's funny though
that's the thing I need a maxwe oh I'm
is it I here here this is Anita maxwin I
guess I don't know where Hispanic came
from I'm sorry he's definitely doing the
accent that he's doing yeah okay good
well yeah the the I'm sorry and
congratulations is separate I kind of
like it too that's what's [__] like
the design is so dumb but it's kind of
Vibes right the layout's not bad and
it's so dumb um I think it is dumb I
don't know you do I don't think it
crosses I'm not I would not wear this
hat would not wear this hat dumb I think
it says steak on one side of it if I'm
not misten oh yeah I noticed that too it
says steak what the [__] are we doing
out here we're selling merch oh my God
golly G willikers man jimy Cricket oh
some people think it sounds Filipino I
honestly don't know okay well some some
it's some sort of an accent that he
trying to
do so what's the line by the way uh AB
he does not say all the n-words are here
so let's issue a retraction and a
correction you know what the word is
exact one just to be 100% started from
the bottom and we're here all right I'm
going to start from the bottom now we
here start from the bottom of the whole
crew here my whole [__] team that's
not what he says
no is that what you're saying he says
yeah now my whole [__] team
here started from the bottom now the
whole [__] team is here all right
after after the okay one of the lines
you said Team here I think this is the n
word so so there is an nword I mean
which is good it's his right
it's his right as it's his privilege so
weird man the N word what said you're so
weird why what do you mean by that
Dan what the [__] fun fact you're so
weird what are you my
mom you're so weird it's a weird thing
to say it's a funny thing to say Dan
it's funny I and that is if you didn't
know my job this is the connection we
share
true PR it's your privilege to you know
[__] on me and and you acknow and you do
that and you do do
that fair enough fair enough half
jewi
um
anyway let's see uh that was a whole lot
of whole lot of this and
that people want you to go to a volcano
Dan I love that idea to throw a Stanley
Cup in I love that idea too yeah I love
it let's let's go sure I'll make that
sacrifice I had pitched because the
barbecue Flames were not hard enough to
pierce the Stanley blood barrier yeah
there's lead in that cup did you know
that I heard you guys talk about it it's
worth mentioning that's why it tastes so
good uh so I had mentioned that Dan
should go to Hawaii throw it in a
volcano sounds fun yeah people want him
to enjoy a in vacation this is a great
idea the question is can you actually
get to a top of a volcano and get that
shot like is that actually I don't think
you need to get to the top of a volcano
because there are just lava flows now
that said um there's I mean is it like
polluting to throw it in lava am I
polluting the lava let's talk you know
what I mean is
that I'm asking genuinely like I don't
believe so because like that's how the
Earth recycles itself it literally it
flows under the crust of another plate
100% I I yeah I'm unsure if just I'm
wondering people would be mad that
throwing things into well we have to
remove it that's part of the experiment
it's got to be attached to some kind of
a drone so you put it this would
actually take a little bit of like we'll
have to consult SCI right like somebody
who actually knows what they're so like
if we could find a lava flow an active
lava flow and a geologist that we could
work with where we can reasonably put
the Stanley Cup in the lava flow why are
we doing marketing for them they should
be paying us like this is crazy ass you
know well you you you were doubting
their marketing that's how it all
started was that you thought you were
calling them out but so far they've been
passing the tests I don't know like all
I know is you don't [__] getting all
superstitious here you don't [__] with
the Hawaiian volcanoes what what's the
sup about that the god hold on hear me
out hear me out that's a new one the
goddess
uhhuh have you ever heard if you take
lava rocks from Hawaii then bad luck
comes upon you so you put no I've never
heard that okay you can search it it's
it's actual it's a um where did you
learn that superstitions aside my
concern was more of just like it yeah I
mean like going to Hawaii and just
throwing stuff you're thinking about
like the ecological both the ecological
like and the cultural like native
Hawaiians might not like us [__] and
and P which I guess is part of that
um you know but if we're not actually
putting it into the lava we're not
taking any rocks from Hawaii we're we're
depositing we will take no rocks I'm I'm
not accusing I'm just saying [__] with
that [__] just don't [__] with we're
dropping off the S apparently it's
illegal to take lava rocks from Hawaii
it's also considered bad luck known as
P's curse there you go taking lava rocks
from the island is said to bring bad
luck and Misfortune upon the thief why
okay nobody wants your lava rocks anyway
why can't take a rock it's so cool
like I'm just thinking if we went there
with you we would probably want to take
a ro also it's like you bring in all
these tourists here it's like a tourist
destination you got all these hotels you
got these be oh but don't take the Rocks
but if well not everybody wants all
those tourists there I think there's
people I guarantee you however the
locals yes however the economy the local
economy the government and all those
people they live on tourism I'm just
saying there a necessary part of their
economy there's stories that people take
the Rocks they actually mail it back to
Hawaii because the the the bad luck is
so bad so I'm seeing that some Hawaiians
believe they view the Rocks as their
ancestors so it's disrespectful okay
that makes sense cuz I didn't I didn't
understand like what's the deal and when
people go there do are they being told
not to do it do people know that I think
so yeah I've never heard that I've never
been but I've never been up to a volcano
either in Hawaii maybe that's you know
different Vibes there's so many rocks
there's so many of them just you know
what I mean I mean everybody says that
and then every you know 100 years pass
and there there ain't no rocks anymore
okay check this out Dan so we can get
close to a lava flow yeah yeah I think
just like interacting with it you would
definitely want like a geologist that
knows what they're doing to uh assist in
that so I would I think I would be okay
with this idea Dan if um we can
basically organize it like I said we
need a geologist we need a plan and we
need a plan to get it out and some plan
to measure the inside of it
and if we can actually get a legitimate
plan I will send you and and Ally who is
there for emotional support film yeah
I'll do it [__] it okay I'll do it well
uh if you uh live in Hawaii or uh or I
guess just anywhere where there's an
active volcano I mean that's just the
first thing that comes to mind true
there could be active volcanoes that are
not are are in the Continental it would
be good to have a local person guide us
to make sure we're not doing anything
disrespectful true I'm just saying Dan I
want you to get a Hawai trip there's
it's not a good idea I'm not taking the
rock he's not we're not the
Rocka just disturbing it just going to
Hawaii is disturbing just being just
[__] interacting with the lava f
[__] with the I'm just saying just
saying I'm warning you you know not to
ruin anything for D but we could make
lava at home you can make lava you can
melt
rock that's interes that would
definitely be cheaper well let's maybe
just sent you to a smelter locally in La
that sounds fun
too fun as Hawaii but that would be
interesting okay let's do that let's
start with that sorry man let's look up
a blackith here play but we be as fun
for D unless I mean the lava flow is
pretty epic yeah I'm somewhat skeptical
that we can arrange this in a
responsible
way people saying Iceland that's true
there are many Iceland's far as [__]
what the
Iceland's cool man you want to go [__]
with the Iceland volcano that's cool you
know what would be the best Dan if you
bring back a rock and then secret
somehow secretly gift it to Zach yeah
put it in his house like give buy him
like a little ukulele and then tape a
rock inside right I'm saying I'm I've
heard horror stories about this I'm just
warning you guys okay yeah it's just
looking you guys out of respect for uh
other people's cultures and uh and faith
I will not touch any rocks but also I'm
not too concerned about upsetting p no p
is not going to be upset because we're
not doing anything disrespectful by the
way we got so I don't know if you guys
heard there's like a new
Subway foot long snack thing going on so
always been wanting to try it oh was
that here we did a big order and they
canceled with us it was just horrible it
was just a nightmare this is a CH mhm
okay there's three items in
total it's that's a bad sh
girl okay at first there's not enough um
sugar on it at first you get that nice
cinnamon flavor but when you get to the
middle you're like that's just bread
just eating bread
stick yeah uh-uh oh everyone
got that this is a p that's actually
really not a good one don't eat that
churro you guys bad I didn't like it at
all you want to try it you know what
pissed me off too in their marketing
they're like a foot long churro it's a
foot long a churo is a foot long minimum
long yeah minimum true foot long CH
that's a small churro that's not
impressive and apparently it's not good
either so not good not good what is even
what am I looking at that's a pretzel
yeah it's a pretzel it looks [__] up
it looks like a look like a worm or yeah
some sort of custm no that looks good
it's not good though I promise so it's I
love prz supposed to be an anti an's
pretzel
and the turl is
Cinnabon collab dude dropping the ball
dude is this the cookie this is what I'm
really concerned about is the foot so
this is definitely the star a foot long
cookie as you know Subway has great
cookies nobody denies that huh wow that
looks good gray no less looks very good
dude should I dump maybe dump it out o
why dump it out no eat it from the tray
I'll put it back in like a pig
look okay that's so
stupid from the middle that's psycho
that's psycho Behavior right in the
middle
bro all right I'm I'm trying I'm eating
from the end
[Music]
though let let me try the cookie so
here's what I'll
say the cookie is oh my God
not bad it's pretty good however the
cookies the cookie cookies are
better cuz it doesn't get um crispy
around the edges no with this it's all
kind of soft it's very soft wow it's
good though it's good that's really
mushy yeah it's like no crisp at all y
yeah some people like it like that so if
you like it a little undercooked no no
no it's not I'm one of those but I like
it to be still crispy on the outside too
this isn't one of those this is just a
yeah ch's a flop dude that CH is try
right now but yeah I don't have high
hobes it has like no cinnamon or sugar
on it yeah it's just it's just a piece
of bread yeah oh give me a break bread
stick give me a break the bread stick is
probably the worst item I want to try
the too here you want to try you they'
done since Jared no that was the the
churro tasted like a bread stick the
pretzel tastes more like [__] the
pretzel all right
the Pretzel was the worst one I think
it's so did you try it yeah I love it
what yeah I love pretzel
bread all right not going to hate I
respect your decision thank you maybe
your pretzel is better than mine mhm
Ricky says you guys want a good churro
go to Don churo Gomez in Anaheim they
have a just a straight up churro shop
I've never heard of that I've been to
not that one but I've been to like
places that specialize in churros yeah I
[__] love churros man what do you
think about the pretzel s tier um I
didn't B tier like not a great pretzel
but i' eat it like it the chur the churo
is like a massive Miss that's like f
tier for me but this like I'd eat this
if I was hungry I think the cookies just
see no the cookie [__] the cookies
better than it's not better than their
normal cookies oh it's
cookie cake I mean listen it's a cookie
of course it's going to taste good yeah
true it's got chocolate you know what I
[Music]
mean I wouldn't recommend any of these
um we have somebody Melanie oh yeah you
see that yeah Melanie says went to
Hawaii for vacation and took home a rock
my mom broke her foot the fridge broke
and my dog got sick within the week of
coming
home
that's Zach thoughts I'm just saying
those are the stories I've heard
H
scary who is p I'm glad we learned this
today because I have never heard that
until now p is the goddess of uh
Hawaii oh so she don't she don't [__]
with people taking her rocks and it's
crazy like sometimes people see her in
the fire like they see the yeah probably
the fumes probably guys want to find a
blacksmith Forge and a sensor that will
record the internal temperature to an SD
card and then analyze the results
afterwards by plotting a graph that's
what I want to do do you know how to do
that because I we needed some I mean I'm
sure we could figure it out how hard
could it
be I mean probably not that hard right I
mean it's doable you've done more
complicated stuff yeah I was serious we
could probably figure it out
um Le Lena Lena said a fissure erupted
on Iceland just a couple of weeks ago
okay right wonderful you don't want to
fly there now it's probably a bad time
or a great time is that the volcano with
like the super long name you know what
I'm talking about it erupted a few years
back in Iceland yeah I think they have
volcanoes erupting pretty much
continuously there was one that erupt it
with this long ass name I'm pretty sure
they're always under threat of like all
dying yeah there was a whole village
that had to be evacuated there was a big
ass crack through the whole city oh [__]
mhm it's kind of crazy it's very
crazy that said shout out to
Iceland you guys want know I've always
wanted to visit there too I'd be happy
with iand beautiful this is my healthy
Subway sandwich I got turkey
mhm
pepper spinach jalapeno
peppercinis
nice um what else is in
here I guess that's it and then
mayonnaise and salt and
pepper uh Scott just donated $5 said I'm
a tour guide on the big island of Hawaii
the island with the active volcano I
would love to take you guys to the
volcano Scott email email me that's good
that's a
start I want we should probably consult
with the an ecologist as well a
geologist ecologist and scientist
somebody who works on that kind of stuff
maybe they have connections yeah I hope
so we can we can open a dialogue here
and meanwhile if you if you operate a
forge or a blacksmith also reach out
right I just I don't know if they have
enough knowledge about dropping a
Stanley Cup into the volcano and how the
goddess would feel about that yeah the
goddess we didn't get her thoughts on
Stanley Cups being so if there's
somebody that it is a weird Gray Zone
isn't it because it's like you can't
don't take the Rocks okay fair enough
but what about dipping in it and then
but it's like I'm not even leaving it
we're just dipping it in the lava right
a dip off it's a dip well does we take a
dip in the in my opinion it's totally
fine I guess we'll see leaving it in
there I think would be fine technically
but we're not even doing that we're
taking it back out how do you take it
back out you got to attach something to
it
yeah we'd have to made of what I'm sure
there's some kind of metal that has a
super high melting point I mean I've
seen lots of videos where like
geologists are doing studies on it and
collecting samples from it and stuff so
that's what I'm saying if we get if we
get a hold of the right person I feel
like they is definitely a method um I
agree and then if it survives that then
we're just going to have to throw it in
like a nuclear reactor or something
shoot it into the Sun be sick not really
sure all right that's exciting my uh
best friend lives in Iceland she may
have some lava in tell oh good lives in
Iceland your best friend lives in
Iceland did she move there H she did she
married someone who is Icelandic does
she like it there or she hate it she
loves it um I've been there too it's
like my favorite place in the world
really yeah it's awesome you go during
night or day no we didn't go during that
season but it's the best during the
summer and the winter it's day and night
all the time that's crazy right almost
uh it's not basic yeah the further north
you go the more pretty wild way to live
I would love to visit a place like that
lowest crime in the world also there's
other good things about Iceland that's
interesting they have all kinds of
interesting stuff happening there they
have the Blue Lagoon super cool you
think they have um you think they have
vampire problems
there like in that movie oh vampires are
from Iceland that's news to me well no
just cuz they
6 months of night yeah it' be the worst
place oh but then yeah but then they
have to hibernate like for a whole right
I guess it even out the blood of God
it's just that it's so concentrated it's
like six months straight of these guys I
just I don't know how long they can
hibernate like before they need to eat
do you think when it's night for 24
hours straight they need to like sleep
or are they just like up and doing their
thing I think they're they're cleaning
they're watching TV yeah depends what
kind of vampires if they're like sexy
vampires like cullins then they're
chilling right what about um serial
killers do we have any of those over
there I don't think so no I lowest
crimee in the world anywhere in the
world I think Iceland serial killer um
yeah results there's one he was known as
the only serial killer in the history of
Iceland his name was
uho I don't know how to it's beorn beorn
beorn what was I also see he lived uh
from 1555 to 1596 holy [__] they gone
like 600 years without a serial killer
that's a good record we got a Ser
calling all serial killers there's
fertile ground over in Iceland they're
not going to ever see you coming man we
should go to Iceland everyone so far
it's a perfect place to strike killing
them murdering like yeah murder it was
murder in there all right one of the
safest countries like you said very low
crime and murder rates H they're too
busy dodging lava flows and [__]
evidently Prime cuz I feel like the
whole country is just like a tiny
Community it's a you know what's the
population of Iceland reallyand
population it's I think I bet it's less
than a million 300 yeah way less
372,000 wow Ventura has that many people
right it's the size of the half the size
of the valley M yeah that's
crazy
everybody knows everybody probably
mhm very
good I cannot wait when the kids grow up
we're going to travel the world Ethan
with or without them I don't care they
can come or they can stay are you mean
like when they're like off the college
type of [__] or like when they're in
high school just when it's like not like
you need like I don't know whenever we
feel like we can go for like 2 weeks
like I guess I don't know what's the
appropriate age for that it is going to
be nice
because this whole time that we I mean
we've been working a lot fornite and you
know these are the work years of being a
adult and also for me living here away
from Israel it's like every time I
traveled somewhere it's to Israel to
visit my family so I'm like so what's
the word amped you're ready to do it I'm
so ready to travel yeah it'll be nice I
and I I have not traveled that much like
I've been only to Germany and
Europe you know probably go there show
up at work and work
harder got get out to Japan you know
Japan I'm dying oh speaking of which
okay so we got to plan a
trip we said let's just go to
Vegas Ela is fairly I mean very pregnant
yeah yeah
we're going to have to get some of those
hats for the tables Z oh my
God we're uh obviously you're pregnant
so being in Vegas is a horrible place
with the smoke yeah ESS smoke everywhere
also I'm getting quite uncomfortable
sitting
lately so I don't know that I can enjoy
it really yeah a geologist with PhD here
I would not recommend this experiment
especially if you think you could pick
the thermos back out L why not whatever
what do you know what do you know
geologist me mind your own business well
so we don't need to like pick it back
out and you know obviously touch it or
like interact with it we just need to
see if the the ice is still intact
inside so like what would it be we would
we would like dip it in lava for just
like a moment or two and then lift it
out and see if there's still a rattle
more than that 30 seconds I don't
know no way 30 seconds is gone it's
melted into into that [__] I'm pretty
sure I don't think isn't it like it's
like 5,000 de isn't it
something especially how hot is when
it's flowing when it's when it's on the
top is probably way L
2,000 that's what the that's what the
flame was is it flame no 4 450 was the
flame well it's different dipping it in
it as well yeah I would think all right
what is that turkey turkey I think
what's this
Pini I don't
know still don't
know okay so the PHD here Mr PhD says
don't do it okay whatever dude this
person said I watched AO about volcano
in New Zealand which erupted while
people were there on tour it is scariest
[__] I've ever seen do not go to an
active volcano tour with peace and love
well tell that to our other viewer who
literally makes their living as a
volcano tour guide It's kind of kind of
messed up to say right I mean the
chances that it explodes while you're
there usually if a volcano is about to
have an explosion there are some warning
signs such as like seismic
activity smoke stuff like this so it's
not like you're going in there and
totally uh chancing it obviously it
can't happen
though um you just got to live man just
got to live man let me throw some life
is all about risks right
so anyway I was saying do you guys want
to go Ela has said that we can go
without her
M boys trip do it no girls just to do it
just the boys that no girls
allowed how did it become no girls only
one girl can't go no he's right no girls
before we let the guys go and then after
Eli has the baby we do a girl strip no I
think it's only fair
I'm against the girls trip bro bro I'm
not a fan of boys trip either dude I
learned from [__] yes never send the
boys alone to Vegas even though you guys
are not that kind of boys but that is
some BS Ethan Klein the boys over there
honestly in Vander pump rules though
it's such a funny meme cuz every time
they went there and they insisted on
going there all the time one of them
would cheat yes one of them would get
blackout someone get in fight like they
are I don't know why they kept wanting
to go
get tattoos yeah oh yeah the worst
tattoo he got a tattoo for his
girlfriend that was so hideous she
demanded he remove it when he showed it
to her yeah it was an A and she called
it the bacon a cuz it looked like it was
made out of bacon it it was so bad can
you pull it up Tom's yes
tattoo this is me in uh this is me in uh
Hawaii by the way you want to keep the
Stanley Cup is that what's happening
refusing you're just like like no I want
the cup yeah it's mine I claim it my
precious ice bearing
cup so I don't know there's that or we
can wait till after the pregnancy but
like I feel like we're never going to do
anything yeah that's the thing I feel
like if we wait then um it's going to be
too much waiting so so let's [__] go
tonight can I go tonight top in the car
yeah she says yeah let's go let's go
right now what are we doing here just
leave the show R Who car you guys want
to go tonight go go tonight thanks for
watching everyone right now raise your
hand if you can go
tonight no hand not one hand AB thank
you AB I guess I can Dan that's what I'm
saying you have to be
spontaneous nobody well if you guys want
to go on
aany trip it's right now or never let me
let me think about it for two seconds
but I know that I have rehearsal
tomorrow but I could if we go to Vegas I
could probably tell them I can't go
so let me talk to them
okay I'll bring in Ethan's
note yeah we can give you a a note mhm
my girl's in Vegas I'm tell you it's
going to be Posh it's going to be
good Zach are you going to fly with us
we can talk about it I really hope you
do it's so fast dude even if you hate
flying I swear to God it's like up and
down we'll uh we'll talk about it
okay all righty then I sent that tattoo
I should probably do the ad and then oh
here it is yeah oh God why is it so
that's the best picture there
is yeah I needed to zoom in a
lot okay so you got it's an a the first
letter of her name on his butt it's just
so ugly and then the other Tom got Bubba
on his but both of them are divorced by
the way both of them are separated yeah
shocking yeah that's real shocking
um let's do our ad and then we can get
into
actually a segment that I've been
waiting to talk about M
the surgery segment mhm
you know we did why it like that we did
a special
preparation we cook something up okay so
let's thank our sponsor you know who
they
are it's
hexclad I love hexclad I love
hexclad I'm one of these people who just
been searching high and low for the
perfect pan basically ever since we came
back and had a kitchen we're like What
is the best pan you know you go you try
stuffff from Amazon you go to Costco we
bought like a super expensive stainless
steel one
mhm this is the pan that I was looking
for the whole time it doesn't scratch it
Cooks beautifully evenly doesn't stick
it is somehow achieved Perfect
Panda some people call it pandemonium M
but in a good way it's pure chaos cuz
people just
cannot get over how good they
are yeah I love them we have the uh I
use them on everything I use them on
when I'm cooking
like from pasta to a steak to a hole in
the bread mhm right it's all happening
on
hexclad you know and I love them um
don't take it from me take it
from the greatest Chef in the world
World Gordon
ramsy hexlab industry leading cookware
doesn't go Ahad stop with pans it's six
piece pot set will perfectly round out
your cooking collection from mashing the
most amazing potatoes to even tempering
chocolate I promise you the combination
of hexagonal Peaks and valleys provides
a Superior Heating conductivity the way
he bounces on his heels is so he's
energetic he's excited to be there tell
you about all the time he goes yeah yeah
he is briming with energy mhm nonstick
service and ultimate durability there's
no limit to what you can do when you
have the very best tools get creative
and Dazzle your family and friends it's
time to get cooking so time to get
cooking Gordon's Ramsey would not lie
about this his reputation was on the
line that's for sure I mean if he likes
it then who are you to say that it's not
perfect who are
you who are you who are you even
yeah I recommend uh let's see I don't I
keep always forgetting to bring my pans
so frustrating cuz
I I use them they're dirty you know like
last time they were dirty and they
didn't look good cuz I just cooked with
them
um trying to find let me just go to
their
website I'm constantly asked what my con
secret we want to show you how cool the
pans look the true the only true High
hbd they say
cookware it's got this really cool
hexagonal
shape which apparently for those
counting that's two more sides than a
rectangle dude rectangles are crying in
shame yeah yeah no they're not no it
apparent the hexagonal shape I guess
makes it stick less and evenly cook I
think the andle scientist it's cuz of
the Peaks and valleys Peaks and valleys
exagonal Peaks and Valley like life
mhm but um the sets are really great I
recommend it big time I love them and
and most of all
they they support our show so if you're
in the business in the lookout for some
beautiful cookware look no further it's
hexclad um let's see here I got a code
for you
guys find your Forever cookware at
hexclad and get 10% off at hexclad
/3 that's it one more
time hexclad
docomo them you got
it all
right oh there's donors well let's thank
them real fast then let me go over to
the we have a
donations
room on Discord so we don't miss any
it's my 27th
birthday says Rose hallow my name is my
name Rex are no oh they Nolan Ren and
Everett by the way today the Gang has
all prepared one perfect name to pitch
us and we are going to put them to the
audience and what whichever one wins we
are going to name our
child 100% guaranteed I don't care what
it is Rumple Ste skin I don't care
is that that's that's it cuz we can't
decide and I'm getting frustrated so if
it's Rumple steel skin if it's uh
fart fart fart are they going to be
serious suggestions yeah suggest it's
the Audi they've all come together with
their most serious suggestion MH that
they're going to pitch to us exciting
Brittney says I remember you saying that
Teddy loves the name Lavender for a girl
how about leer for a boy boy leer ler
linger to let it linger wait what's ler
it's like um young lean's last name is
Leander oh Leander maybe I'm saying it
wrong Leander Leander that's nice that's
interesting name I like it um Montana
Joe th Ethan thirst chat rise up you
look hot King and Ela incredible as
always thank you thank you it's a little
long on the top it's a bit broccol it's
broccoli esque
not full broccoli Shana says please if
anyone wants to send your prayers for my
family I lost my mom last night due to
heart failure and car crash all your
prayers are greatly appreciated at the
moment I know she's in a better place oh
my
God uh sorry about that sorry for your
loss it's horrible sorry to hear
that love
you
um love you all right where do we go
from
there this is not a Dono but someone
said this earlier I forgot to mention
they said the person that was sitting at
the counter when you're doing the [__]
test probably knew you were a fan and
that's why they said that the toilet
wasn't working cuz I knew he would clog
it oh well hold on uh genius I'm
[__] in a [__] receptacle that's
true and then I dump it in afterwards so
there's no there's no
like
towel uh engineering there could be love
there's a f Fest happening in Chicago
next month huh what that's weird look
into that V says lie to me like you used
to I don't know what that
means I would never lie to you I've
never
lied uh Athan Klein a mix of Ethan name
and
duckies also pull to see the superior
race watching H3 what the
[__] what PLL to see the superior race
watching H3 you want me to like PLL
people's
races like a
census uh all there's actually too many
I just I I feel bad there's too many
what's going on
here I'll do more after at the end yeah
thank you everybody though for your
support thank you thank you guys thank
you so much thank you to the members
all right so up next Let's see we got
options we can do the baby naming game
or we can do
the uh plastic surgery segment which
we've done a little something spicy and
nice with okay you have a
preference selfishly I want to do the
baby name but whatever we'll get to both
I'm curious what the people think
actually yeah if they're um
if they're invested in the baby name
situation or maybe they want a spicy
thing I'm curious what the people
want uh that's me you doing a poll is
that sure that was I don't know if that
was translated and what I was saying I
was picking up on that
mhm let me see if I got my test results
oh I got
it all right I'm about to find out if I
need to do a colonoscopy or not oh
God Dr D Jake ditt you
watching somebody clip this and send
this to Jake this was my
[Music]
ass okay looks like I have
one it's a parasite andic pathogen panel
[Music]
I am negative for a parasite thank God
for that parasite me good it was they
tested me for
jaria
cryptosporidium an ENT mooba and and
andoba all right that's it you that's it
Zach all right we got one okay
good
all
right someone send that to uh Jake
dittle
please thank
you no Ethan that's not how that works
well I need your con I need your consent
before I move forward with any treatment
oops me and me and my doctor for forgot
to consult with
you um well
[__] hey Ethan love you you guys Britney
says my name is ideas are Fenner Archer
Apollo Kane and
Dakota those are nice I appreciate the
suggestions they're out of the box you
know oh people want the baby name okay
we'll do the baby name we'll do the the
plastic surgery thing afterwards it's
all going to be fun okay we we'll we'll
slam right through the baby name thing
all right go here's the deal welcome
everybody the baby game me and Ela are
incapable of deciding on a name and so
put this together for you the people and
here my trusted uh
crew each one has picked their very
favorite one name for our beautiful soon
Tobe born boy yes I don't know if he's
beautiful I haven't seen him yet he'll
be beautiful no matter what
statistically speaking
though we have a 100% beautiful baby uh
rate so he might come out and be like
yesh broke the streak on that one
eh probably not probably not
probably thank you so who wants to go
first yeah and so we're going to put it
to the audience the one that wins we are
going to name our child 100% No Cap as
the kids at home say might say to you
okay the kids around the world are
saying to each other yeah no cap no cap
on a stack I don't think I believe you
well let's do the game you'll find
out also um I'm just going to say up
front uh I don't have one what what can
come up with one I thought about it a
lot you have to that's not helping me at
all D you're not care I don't know what
to say I I tried to come up with I mean
you guys should sympathize you've been
trying to come up with a name and you
couldn't all right let's start with you
Lena it wasn't for a lack of trying but
it was supposed to be a serious
suggestion I made it hard I got lots of
joke suggestions but like I don't know
what there's not one that you like like
kind of at least something you can put
forward not really not even a single one
I mean there's so many that we've talked
about too it's just like I don't know
maybe something will come to you we'll
see all right uh whoever's got one yeah
I can start I have go ahead so we just
say what ours is you guys have a group
you've as a group come
together you and ab oh we have separate
names no we have
yeah go ahead say what it is anyways
mine is Ezra
Ezra that's nice mhm what is the what I
will say it's kind of cool here in
Israel not so much is that an Israeli
name mhm it's like an old guy Ezra a
meaning I means helper helper yeah it's
from it's from the word help
Lazo
okay I like it though I mean that's one
that we hadn't considered which is I
appreciate when it's something it's been
suggested to me by Vi actually okay yeah
I think it's sweet I like it thank you
Lena Ezra Star Wars
character the little ducklings I'm about
to have a new Duck to the family all
right AB then if you just pull them up
the little tabs it'll reveal
it go look at that what that was cool
that's awesome that was really cool oh
you know the names already are you
typing it no no we know him already yeah
I got the graphic cam is the only one
that knows
every I I said
Levi okay I like Levi oh you you're a
dork though for that big dork well no
this is my major dork alert it's an
attack on Titan well a few things the
boy like lavender it's sort of sounds
like that also it's a Hebrew name mhm
but 99% [__] Captain Levi baby
honestly it was on our list Levi is a
really good name yeah hell yeah
I really like that it's a cool name Levi
yeah I like
it but you got to say it like the way
they do in the Japanese version Levi
like that
Levi I wonder if in Hebrew that would
become Levy I don't know maybe somebody
in the chat would know anime Watchers
you guys notice how
like what they say on
screen wait what am I
saying what I'm about to say doesn't
make any sense so I sto myself I'm
trying to reformulate my thoughts okay
right just saying calculating calcul
like when they reading the when it the
Japanese is written out like
phonetically in English or like names
specifically that that's what where you
see it a lot like the what they write in
the English letters has like no bearing
at all on how they actually say it it
confuses the hell out of me when I'm
trying to figure out how to say it names
like like a
uh what's his s What's that name SAS SAS
and they spell it like s
k Suzuki you're saying like in the uh
Clos captions the yeah well however they
spell it phonetically you know in
English right or not I guess it's not
phonetically I don't know who decides
how you spell that [__] I'd like a re I
like a redo on that who describes how we
spelled in English is there a panel
that's a good I think just
[Music]
convention all right love let's do it in
order you go ahead me all right so I
harness the power of AI AKA Shad gbt cuz
I was much like Dan a very hard hard
time to personally pick one M yeah so I
asked shad gbt and I didn't just ask
after a good name I asked a name that
would fit Bruce and theater and the genu
genuine response was Oliver that's crazy
and and I I know obviously we know
someone named Oliver that sucks but I
think since you guys actually like that
word you shouldn't let that stop you
guys MH and we should take over Oliver
like the word Oliver make make it the
baby's name and [__] Oliver tree cuz he
don't deserve that name and then I I
don't even know if that's his real name
frankly probably it's just a stage name
probably anyways genuinely I don't know
then I asked for probably Sean or some
[__] I been thinking about it that maybe
that's why we're having such a hard
because it was going to be Oliver
probably mostely and then we all started
talking about like but Oliver tree well
Scotty was the original one and we were
like I didn't think about it for a long
time it's like Scotty um I think it was
Oliver before Scotty even oh I think so
too from what I've heard I do love that
name and I think it's perfect and cute
and it fits and I also asked for like
some this this I asked for afterwards
just a list of things like one thing
that um stuck out International appeal
that actually stuck out to me because I
know a lot of Olivers all over Europe in
very many languages that it works so and
even in Hebrew it works ESS what the
[__] harmonizes with sibling name it
complements well the classic names like
Bruce and Theodor creating a cohesive
set of names what do they mean by that
Theodore
theu I agree with that I agree it's a
good vibe classical yeah just seems like
they're want a bunch of smoke up our ass
GPT no no no no this
is this is it okay okay that's a good
one I mean that that's a golden one yeah
I think you guys should stick to it
absolutely love Oliver me too let me
wrap this up I'm done guys all right all
right up next Samantha Samantha so I
picked a first and a middle name I
thought we were supposed to do both
that's fine okay I picked art Lorenzo
Klein art oh so not arur it's art no
just art art
Lorenzo know art Lorenzo Arty okay I
like it Castle 's a cute name for to
call your kid mhm yeah like a nickname
Arty um I like Arty as a nickname Art's
nice like it mhm I like the
Lorenzo unexpected well you guys seem to
uh when we talked about it last time you
liked a lot of like Italian inspired
names yes I thought it was kind of a
Vibe
mhm those Italians they will be
7.5% Italian so it's not Stolen
Valor I like it thank you
Sam course
Ian uh okay I like names that sound up
with the literation like M you
know mhm yeah so I'm pitching Casey
Klein Casey
[Applause]
Casey Casey K I do like the
alliteration sometimes you need that you
remember it you know people change their
names for the alliteration you they come
to Hollywood and they say I need I need
it to be that pow pow right I don't know
what you guys are talking about it's
when the the beginning of both the words
have the same
sound like Calin Klein yeah I like Casey
Casey's nice Casey you're Idol the only
person you love more than me
yeah Casey okay thank you Ian I like it
very welcome thank
you
Olivia okay so the name that I am
suggesting is
LCA Luca brzi Luca Klein Luca
Luca Luke thank you luk l u would it be
l u CA l u CA yeah Luca that's cute all
right well I don't like Ryan saying it
it makes me feel icky about it it's a
valian origin means bringer of
light like luk Skywalker love that thank
you Cam hi so you guys kind of like
unique names you were throwing out ducky
and Buster at first and all that so I
kind of went with one that I haven't
seen too often and I picked uh Salem
Xavier Klein
Salem named after my favorite small city
of M
Salem named after my favorite uh Mass
murdering
event it's a beautiful small City though
beautiful Town Xavier I like the Xavier
we could call him professor X is Salem
like Salam or is that a different I say
Salem no it's it's Salem it's a
different word yeah different word yeah
Sal similar two but Salam um Xavier
Klein
is kind of doe
too yeah what does Salam mean Salam
means greeting like Shalom hello oh it
does Salam alayum what does malum mean
it's just it means like my baby you say
it means like right back at you right
back it means like yeah hello peace be
upon you then like right back at you
more peace upon you my friend even more
peace
alayum
yeah I'm teaching brother I'm going to
I'm going to convert him by the end of
the year okay no I'm kidding Mas he knew
that already cam you're on a watch list
now is that no good should I button that
is it
funny I thought it was funny it's fine
all right I in my head I was like I
think it's funny but I might have to
bail thank
you
uh
Zachariah so you guys you like those
kind of classical type names um I
thought the name Sylvester would uh oh
Sylvester yeah you can call him you know
Sly or sill or um ivester
turv V Sylvester I think it would be
very actually I like it it's cool
suffering suff attack suffer yeah so
what it almost seems related to Buster
like Sylvester Buster Sylvester
kin I don't know I think it'd be fitting
and it's I like it thank you Z I love
the U good suggestion I think you guys
all really brought great great names
here
unexpected unique wonderful names and
Dan is a comment Dan didn't do his
homework Dan I need your name I don't
have one about just Dan I even asked
Ally for help yeah Dan I think would be
the
submission you
know I sound too full of
myself you think good name good Daniel
Daniel it served me great how to serve
keemstar and I know a lot of other
Daniel oh [__] that's true keemstar I
was about to say that Dan Daniels are
gen generally good guys but that is I gu
exception to every rule yeah
exactly all right so you don't want to
put anything in there Dan you want to
put Dan I mean you want to put keemstar
Keem star wait wait wait I got I got I
got
got what you got z z up with Mega Man
yeah Mega Man oh Mega Man clim that's
kind of fire yeah why not Mega
Man I like Mega Man me man you want
that no this is these are serious names
that was the thing is it like I can I
can come up with joke names suggestions
but I I just couldn't nail one that that
felt right all right so Dan is uh he's
uh abstaining from voting yep IDK clone
leave me out of this so now the idea is
that the people get to vote and the name
is the name that's it we're done it's
over really should we should we add into
the mix the one that we kind of added
lately or
[Music]
not maybe we should do a round with
these names and then have whatever wins
that compete against the name you're
talking about mentioned that but
well
yeah um let's go ahead what was that AB
sorry
nothing what what what happened oh
nothing I was going to say we could
potentially have all these compete and
then that name goes against the name you
guys were referring to but it looks like
you guys moved on so I said I'm out I'm
out so can we put all these up on a
poll have to do an off YouTube one for
that many what the people would vote for
people like
Oliver yeah I know that I do know that
and I people know that we know they know
that we like Oliver
right
so I might actually pick
that I think that's the most likely
although I'll
say I can't see anything else winning
frankly than Oliver Le Levi is nice Ezra
nice
art Casey they're all nice they're all
nice Luca is really cute too I actually
feel like Luka long is does anybody hope
that I don't pick their name because
they want it for their baby I already
have my baby names picked out so can you
tell me what I I'll tell you later I
actually wanted to name my son Bruce if
I ever had a kid named Bruce really yeah
you guys you guys got are you serious
that's awesome I love that cuz that name
is is like I got so much push back yeah
I never met anybody else that was down
with the name honestly except Ethan
people were even sending me memes of
tweets with like hundreds of thousands
of lik imagine having a boy and naming
him Bruce I love it dude it's great you
know what it fits him so perfectly now
it's like I love it I love the name with
him it's perfect and the baby's not
going to be a baby forever too you know
it's a long-term investment there exact
it's exactly it's like Apple at you know
30 years ago for now for now he's Brucey
and it's super cute yeah it's so cute I
I named my name's after somebody I grew
up
with that was my pick for it I've never
known an older person named Cameron like
they're all like your age or younger
isn't that weird well I never met
another Cameron at all you too I've
known a few Camerons growing up really I
think it was just a popular name when we
were uh we we lad than we are know
somebody said
Baer it's a name mix of Buster and
Rex rexter Art Van delay art
vlay soda
Klein I don't hate we thought about that
honestly soda yep but I feel like it's
more for a girl for some
reason yeah so it's up let's go
guys the results of this are binding
whatever it is whoa we're putting it to
the T we're putting it to rest and it's
kind of as I predicted that it would be
Oliver
everybody is saying Oliver
Klein me and Lena have always had a name
picked out for a girl if we had a girl
but we never said it cuz we're afraid
her sisters will take it or my cousin
but I was thinking maybe I should but no
if you say it then they can't take it
right maybe if I say it here on air
that's like a tap tap seat it's yours
okay say can you switch to me Ian I need
to be able to show this in case it ever
comes up we want to name our daughter
Evelyn and then Eevee for short Evelyn
MH that's really cute yeah there was um
make sure your sisters see this just tap
tap we have the proof now so does mean
they have to like respect it I don't oh
they're going respect that' be crazy if
they named it they're I'm honestly her
sisters are respectful I'm not worried
about her sisters I'm more worried about
my cousins oh yeah the cousins they they
can do anything yeah
there was the musician called Eve I
think when I was growing up I used to
listen to her songs and she would go
like e v e and I thought it was so cool
it's for me my grandma's gwendaline and
I grew up at her house and her favorite
movie was the mummy the main character
is Evelyn in that movie that's nice
gwendaline that's a nice name too yeah I
like eie being short for it yeah that's
a cute name well it looks like the
people have spoken we have 7,000 votes
in but there's a clear statistical
winner here it's Oliver Klein with
nearly 40% of the vote M now let me say
this y'all really thought I was going to
let you guys decide the name of my
child give me a
break we decided on a name oh
whoa did we I think so oh I don't know
if we did I think we did I don't know if
we did did did did I think it's that one
oh my God but we have been saying all of
last week that like maybe it's Oliver
maybe it's just got to be Oliver so no
I'm I'm I'm in on this one okay let's
say it oh wow so here is the real name
we think do you want to Dan Dan went to
the restroom he doesn't care about what
my baby's called he doesn't care about
this tring to bece just trying to be
nice held it if he cared about me at
all you
know okay here's the
name with peace and love
M I hope you like
it if you don't I'm still
going the name
is after much deliberation and
thought list on
list Consulting with family friends no
we didn't oh and the new name we didn't
well in general mhm mhm we have come
together oh [__] Anson's is here no
way that's a perfect
timing oh it's heavy too this baby name
is brought to your this so what I'm
going to smash the subway cookie with
the
ANS so here the name
is I don't want to
here
Sunny
oh spelled like s u n n y like sunny I
you know I actually recom I love that
name and IED it and I tried to change it
but cam made the graphic
already can something oh my God I'm so
glad you didn't because I didn't want
you didn't want to pick from the I yeah
I didn't want to so I went out to go get
the uh the Anson so you guys had a name
and you lied and made all of us stress
about coming up with these names he li
no intention of using it no intention I
was kind of ready to use the the winner
I my the whole thing was I thought I
explained my
you did but I was kind of like because
then El was like we should put the name
we're thinking of us and I was like no
no no that's not like no no no no that's
not
it
um I said do you all really think I
would let you guys name my child my son
right so anyway that's believable yeah
it is well they they all believed
it but we said sunny I don't know if you
heard I heard the sunny part
yeah
Sunny Sunny On A Rainy
afternoon Sunny hey Gabe hey what's
going on we just we just
announced we just announced our um our
baby name Sunny yep
[Music]
sunny [__] yeah nice shirt how you doing
hey I'm good I'm repping A3 I'm repping
Teddy fresh [__] it's King's Day so I'm
having a [__] Pizza let me see what
you're working on Gabe is eating pizza
ladies and gentlemen baby oh that's a
fat that's a fat crust who made that F
pizza [__] Pizza who made that don't you
think the crust is obscenely big on that
pizza dude pizza kind of [__] you on
that pie
dude don't you think probably hurt my
[__] drink oh then they forgot your
drink too my [__] drink but let me
see the pizza again oh you're getting
fed nice that's
respect oh yeah Gabe looks thin yeah let
me see the pizza you guys see what I'm
saying look how [__] big the crust is
it's like half the damn pizza he's
already at the crust is it is it stuffed
is the crust stuffed Gabe stuff with
bread stuff with [__]
all right well how's it taste at least
is it good at least it's good
nice that's a one I this my my second
one oh the K now that's a pie yeah look
at that now that's a pie right there my
friends Gabe is he's got two different
pies potentially from two different
locations they look so different mhm now
now which slice did you like better the
the bigger the Breer one or the thinner
one I go with the um bigger one because
ask me are you like that one better yeah
and what is it you like about that
one the dough you like the dough I like
the dough I like the it looks
doughy you there go ahead and have a
yeah go ahead drink I love pizza and I
love people thank you I'll
wait did you know Pizza is actually very
nutritious ious Pizza is actually very
nutritious
yeah all right well I'm happy for you
seems like you've got a great weekend
ahead starting with pizza it's hard to
go you know have a bad weekend after
that yep we're going to noru for the
weekend having the best sushi nice in
nor
nice I've never been there actually mean
I'm not a big Sushi consumer but I've
never been to noou but I hear everybody
they love no
mhm best atmosphere out there really
Gabe I recall you saying you don't like
sushi
yeah okay so so so what's the real story
here Gabe are we going to
noou
yep wait now I don't believe you Gabe
what are you actually
doing see you you can't get anything by
us we know everything we know Uncle
gab I don't really have sushi but I
could have something else like salmon or
something okay okay that's true did they
offer cooked salmon at at noou let's
open the
menu I'm gonna get to the bottom of this
Gabe I I think I've looked at the noou
menu because we've thought about going
there and I specifically remember it's
only like raw fish which is why I never
ate there oh hell yeah That's my boy
that's a double bite it has other stuff
they do okay it it checks
out there it is what a good time back
there all right gab well it's nice to
see you nice to hear from
[Applause]
you [__] baby Cameo you're on Cameo
that's where it all goes down for Uncle
Gabe he's gonna woo wish you a [__]
baby
wish you a [__] [__] L you a
[__]
[__] I love you
Ethan oh thanks buddy I love you
too
good
one that was good all right have a great
weekend Gabe we love you keep crushing
it on Cameo BR brother great all
[Applause]
right how about that one
[Music]
bit all right
bit that's uh that's Uncle Gabe
the art the artist formerly known as
white CL so are we all loving
sunny I love it I do have a question
yeah is it to like further uh Ethan's
Godfather narrative that he's naming his
son Sunny CU The Godfather son's name
was sunny are you serious his oldest
know well it's the son that died so I'm
not you know but no I just didn't know
that that's kind of cool frankly it's
not like an homage but I do remember
watching that movie and thinking Sunny
was a cool name although that his name
was short for some Italiano Santino
sanoon he was cool they assassinated him
though they took him out they Massacre
my boy they Massacre my boy look at my
Sunny what did they do to my boy and
that's how you got Al paccinos yeah cuz
his big brother was slain Cold
Blood Tiffany says that's my future baby
named
thevery She's spelling it Sunny like s o
n n y see that one I respect to me it's
really important that it's the s u NN y
yeah cuz Sunny's like hey sunny boy yeah
come on down here now sunny boy and I'm
I'm more thinking about like a sunny day
yeah
Sunny now does Sunny work with Scotty
because it's SS Sunny Scotty Klein it's
Vibes it's Vibes is it Vibes yeah I like
it yeah it's the alliteration that we've
been looking for it's SS deer
SS like not like Nazi stuff you're
saying it's double s tier not like s
like secret
police it could be there was like Nazi
St right that was SS yeah it was the
uh they're uh secret police right they
were real bad dudes
MH okay well it's sunny so there it is
everybody thank
you thanks for playing although I have
to say lovely lovely suggest
I do love the suggestions they were very
nice thank
you thank you sunny it's a great now you
guys you have a sunny and a Fredo in the
family oh [__] we're just missing a
Michael right Michael and
Connie you have a son named Michael
right well according to Oliver tree
who's a liar and a thief and a
[Music]
fraud um all right well thank you let's
move on now to the plastic surgeon
sketch that I've been wanting to talk
about this for so long is
truly I don't even know how to say it
it's it's astounding it it's it's
shocking I mean the first time I saw
this video I was stunned into silence
for a few minutes okay hold on hold on
before we move on people think the SS is
a problem
why um they didn't say why they're just
probably kidding it's a problem no
they're not
kidding why not well [__] them I don't
care you know what I mean I'm committed
this is it this is like when I got
latched on the bru yeah and I was like
no come on it's
Bruce and everyone's like are you sure
are you sure
yes there's a lot of good people with
initials SS Sylvester Stallone oh
okay but it's his middle name nobody
cares about middle names his name would
be SK mhm which is my brother's initials
actually M right
mhm all right so we can move on all
right so here is the video that shocked
me into
silence um I don't know if you've seen
this I think I may have shown it to you
to me um and it it it's going viral for
obvious reasons well not that Viral this
only has 60,000 likes
oh okay hold on
wait why is it showing that okay yeah
before look at this this is him he came
to Dr Kim for Rejuvenation and they
turned this man
it's
into I mean what do you even say I mean
I've
never I've never seen anything like
it they pulled his skin so hard you can
see like the creases in it
oh I'm being told that's his actual
that's his actual face what happened
they literally you can see the scar
lines around his whole face like they
cut his whole [__] face off and
pulled that [__] tight like a drum yeah
I was trying to figure out what they did
I was watching some other doctor talk
about it and during a face lift you
remove skin by the ears and you pull
back the face with him it looks like he
did the whole the whole thing I've never
seen like the scars on the forehead like
that I think he looks
good no he looks way younger he does I
mean he looks young he doesn't look
human though they changed his species
let's see the before again very pretty
he's a chang here he
is he's a nice Dad he's a good that's
why so much was pull bro that's crazy
what the [__] that mouth where he where
is his
mouth and again I listen all love and
respect to these people he doesn't have
much lips in the before I don't you can
blame that on
I think he looks great
mhm this is usually I people say what
about when it heals this was like I
think it said seven days after yeah like
a few weeks after already I am curious
however it in I'm curious how it looks
like now that everything healed fully
well there's a reason he don't show
those Dr Kim keeps them off his page
after two weeks it's hard you can't find
anything for anyone homie went from 51
to creature
man and we him you know it's not your Dr
Kim just has an interesting style yeah
he turned him into like a br doll or
whatever you call it like I don't know
what what the [__] man
Bratz I still don't even really know
what that means I just just remember
Trisha saying it all the time brats doll
remember those dolls they were the best
dolls they're called Bratz like brats
with a z cuz they're kind of edgy I
didn't know that I didn't know what I
was say cooler Barbie yeah they're like
the it girls of the Dolls okay it was
fast my time as a kid but uh everybody
knows about it I didn't play with dolls
I didn't either but it was know about it
I was doing masculine [__] like riding
bicycles
and playing with action figures [__]
sick me too Stretch Armstrong remember
that I didn't have that he was so
stretchy dude I had this random memory
like you you all remember Stretch
Armstrong of course it was this it
was in my adulthood but I know what
you're talking about it was so cool like
I don't think we'd ever seen anything
like it it was this really strong but
also very pliable rubber that you could
stretch and stretch and stretch and it
wouldn't break was so fun so cool oh
yeah there it is yeah and um I was over
my friend's house like my best friend at
the time used to hang out all the time
time I don't know what happened but we
were in the backyard We Were Young by
the way so I don't know I don't remember
how old but that kids and there's like a
hole in his backyard and then we just
put it in the hole and start peeing on
it and then his mom came outside and was
like what the [__] are you doing she she
never I think she never she blamed that
on me and I don't even I don't think
that that was even my idea but she I I
would never she looked at me the same
after that
yeah cuz that's weird as [__] weird how
old were you you think when you did
this it's so hard to place it maybe like
Elementary School under 10 a lot under
10 eight seven little kids do weird [__]
yeah kids do weird I'm telling you I'm
just warning you now Ela as our boys
come closer to like yeah that age be
prepared for weird weird stuff they're
already like
they like want to be naked and run
around and dance uhuh and then they do
this dance where they're like I'm going
to show you they're just like this while
they're naked even Bruce does
it oh it's so funny and I just I don't I
already don't know what to do dude
they're so funny they're so happy when
they get their clothes off and they just
start running around like m going naked
baby Brucey says naked
baby
yeah um
anyway let's look at more there's a
whole bunch here this is the this video
has a compilation it's this doctor
talking about it which I don't really
care about I'm just going to not worry
about him so this is our
boy golly [__] gwiz on that one seven
days after it says yeah now look at her
she's pretty young lady mhm looks good
looks
fine now with the little
magic
Jesus she looks like a [__] Skyrim
character creation gone wrong looks like
even old she looks like an oblivion
character right I mean she got what
happened to the earlobes bro I don't
know why are they like horizontal he he
for sure re built her an
SD reilt her an
SD like what the [__] I've never seen
anybody that looks like that in my whole
life confused about the mechanics of the
ears I don't know what to say this doct
like straight out he just pulled it all
down not be a doctor yeah how is this
healthy like if he is a doctor he
couldn't find anything MH you couldn't
learn anything about him we I looked
around yeah we all looked his WhatsApp
is the only link he has connected and he
has no bio and his WhatsApp bio is just
hello but his like his Tik Tok bio says
no bio yet like he typed that in here's
the thing these surgeries are definitely
happening like I don't know who this Dr
Kim is but these are real people having
their faces cut off yeah yeah I but can
it can it last a few years or they going
to be okay nobody knows man so here's
this lady she's you know definitely got
some
age here she is honestly that one's
pretty nuts like hello
youthful hello incredible she's ready to
mingle now these are all good yall are
just haters I mean to be real though
this one is kind of impressive mhm they
just like had four people just pulling
her skin back on her face CRA it's just
like setting a drum yeah it looks good
doctor I can't feel my face though yeah
well I when we oh wait I'm about to
spoil something never
mind three days after oh that's three
days after she's healing
great yeah if you go to his page it's
all just straight
bananas let's see I saw some people
saying that even his profile picture is
generic it's probably not him if you do
do a reverse image search for his
profile
picture cuz his the picture is like a
really nice generic young professional
looking Doctor yeah and I know that's
not doctor that's not Dr K this dude is
not Dr k for all I know these people
could be kidnapped and the subject of
human
experimentation all yeah I'm might be
what's happening here this one
is let's see
[Music]
seven
before what I mean what the [__] this
one's kind of impressive too that one
it's it's less that it looks bad it's
more is that really the same person it
looks like a different person agree well
that which is funny in a different way
yeah is it it might be though I I think
it's the same
person she everything about her is
different everything looks different
dude look he cut her neck he cut her
skin at the [__] neck I mean I think
they do that this dude cut all around
her
face holy smokes man oh my God [__]
face off dude Absol lady is from South
Korea she found us on Tik Tok and saw
her smile it was all worth it okay so
she that does make sense oh that's the
description he says she found him on Tik
Tok yet we can't find any way to get a
hold of him or find out anything about
him well she probably whatsapped him
yeah I think so let's WhatsApp him and
see you want
Topp him I'd like to just know more
about him just say hey we run the big a
huge podcast right now influential
podcast and we'd love to talk about your
professional uh love to love to love to
love to okay Ethan I found another
doctor with that's yeah that's not his
name so that's a stolen profile picture
yeah which is shady as a mother that's
the whole thing this is so like surgery
in the back of a truck so shady these
are real surgeries and you have someone
with a fake picture
posting that it was
him she found him on Tik
Tok that's the same person you can tell
where where can you tell the nose uh the
eyes yeah yeah it's the same person
all right well I mean I feel like this
one isn't that bad I think what there's
a lot going on there's some filters
going on on the after she became like a
too young she has the same left nostrils
she's like 12 now yeah that's definitely
her yeah I think there's some uh filter
because in all the befores you can see
like all their pores and [__] and then
that after it's like all of the sudden
he he did would you he remove your pores
too no this some flattery going on here
for
sure but um well another success story
by Dr Kim let's keep looking CU I am
endlessly
fascinated look at this that's a
[Music]
dub
Buton that
cuz I just I button that cuz last time
that
happened just showing that screen yeah
that's silly it is so so silly nothing
was even shown yeah okay sorry about
that Folks at least uh we didn't give
you um a light show this time true this
one's so here she is I mean let's be uh
you know
she's you
know not quite sure what language are
they speaking give me the
volume oh yeah she's saying help me
please I'm I'm at 213 seven Wolf Street
I think this is all in South
Korea but why would she say she's from
South
Korea if if it's all in South Korea I
feel like this is in China oh maybe
there's there's there's got to be
somewhere with like very little medical
oversight not that China is has no
medical oversight but I feel like that
country is so big and there's so much
going on there and there's there's a lot
of you know the reason I suggested South
Korea on top of the fact that there's
several of these that said that they
were Korean is that um we were looking
this up the other day uh I looked up the
stats and South Korea has the highest
plastic surgery rate per capita in the
world so they they are into their
plastic surgery their plastic surgery is
really
good it's crazy good they look very
natural like you couldn't really tell
totally like they're experts at it
evidently yeah it's like you know um
when we get our braces everybody just
accepts that as normal I think I feel
like in South Korea it's like that for
like do their nose and their eyelids and
[__] it's
crazy the photo I found of the actual
doctor he well the address they have is
in South Korea oh [__] so this dude is
actually butchering people in South
Korea well I I mean the No No the yeah
the the stolen profile picture was from
a Korean doctor doesn't really mean
anything yeah so who knows but because I
do think Korean plastic surgeons are
very uh well-renowned or a lot of them
anyway I said no pickles what language
is it what what the [__] Google godamn
people are saying he's in Shanghai so
that's perhaps he his first TI it's in
Chinese it's in Chinese yeah that that's
in China his first Tik talk is Geo tag
to Singapore oh they speak Mandarin
Chinese and Singapore uh Singapore
actually uh its main language is English
um but I think there's I think this
dude's in China I'm telling you this
dude's in China the look what he look at
this [__] spoken there
bro come on oh come on
whoa oh my God oh my
God it's one of four official languages
just spoke in Singapore oh okay I this
dude's in China though oh is this Dr Kim
oh that looks like Dr Kim oh my God
those scars wait is this the same
account I think you might have oh [__]
this is somebody else yeah this is
somebody else oh so wait is this a fat
oh yeah cuz his looked
more his didn't look as crazy this
account has very gory stuff on it
just yeah these ones look way I mean
well that's pretty
intense pretty intense wait then how the
[__] oh cuz I just searched for facelift
in
Chinese that'll do
it thank you all right let's see who El
people saying they're Chinese trying to
seem Korean with fake photo
slame oh maybe because South Korea has a
good reputation surgy they're trying to
portray that bro why is what what the
[__] okay hold on on I don't want to be
mean but I mean she's in China she
doesn't has no idea who I am or never
see this but like you know when you're
[__] around in
like I mean I say this but it really is
a Wii Avatar like when you make the
cheeks all big this is the before by the
way so I'm just being a
dick
exactly she's in the she's what she's
doing she's in the uh character creation
right now there it
is okay that one isn't that bad it's not
I mean not great but I liked her better
before yeah I apologize I just saying
she has puffy cheeks that's all like in
a good way like a beautiful well she was
insecure about it enough to go get
surgery thanks to people like you I mean
she could probably stash so many acorns
in those things all right clap
those
God ducky he was under your chair um oh
my God
Jesus
[__] what is everybody yelling TUV video
or tub video what is this did he just
fart po himself okay did he poop
himself poor
thing he he does that sometimes he gets
all curled up under the
chair poor
thing Alfredo's checking on him oh what
a sweetheart Alo
no is he okay you want to go say
Mom probably got spooked mostly from
what I saw I've always been so scared of
that happening I know [__] I just moved
back a tiny bit it must have
foot I I don't think his feet I think
he's okay from what I saw he just go
spooked yeah I'm touching his feet to
see if he is feeling any pain I think
he's okay yeah he'd be yelping when he
squeeze it like thaty I'm so sorry so
now he's just Hamming it up for
attention poor me oh poor me it's not
fair did that happen it's so not fair
that should never happen Who the hell's
throwing tomatoes for ducky in the chat
someone said dead there
[__]
off better than dead
dog Alfredo now hi Alfredo he's the best
by the way such a good dog ducky yeah
he's so cute and so sweet and so
[Music]
smart so anyway I was inspired by Dr Kim
I could watch these all day frankly um
and maybe we will
but um I've been
inspired by his Artistry have you yeah
you can see what what some what just a
little bit of good work can do for a
person and I've been on this journey of
self improvement I've lost weight I got
a haircut I'm wearing pants MH wow and
you know there's one most impressive of
all there is one final frontier okay my
face really people always say you can't
F you know you got a face only a mother
could love you know you can't change
your face they says can't change ugly
you can't fix ugly who says that well I
posture what if you could go ahead Ian
anyway get a load of what myON says he
keeps calling me ugly and he keeps
calling Ela ugly bullying people in
[__] check get the [__] out of here
if you don't like getting bullied go to
[__] H3 I don't know someone needs to
bully [__] Ethan class so he can lose
some goddamn weight and get away from
that ugly [__] that he's married to I
mean you know what it's like oh why do I
care what bullies think you know I'm
successful I'm a mature I've got kids
I've got a wife like I couldn't care
less about what this guy thinks about
me all right well thanks for
watching we'll see you next
time thank you
guys thank you good work today
everyone good work Olivia high five
always Ian great switching today buddy
apprciate it you nailed it was really
funny you nailed it you're the man you
too
go to [__] H3 I don't know someone
needs to bully [__] E the class so he
can lose some goddamn weight he's fat
he's short he's clearly lonely he's
wearing [__] baggy ass shorts he
finally took off the mask let's go dream
let's hope uh Ethan Klein takes his off
next oh I'm being told that's his actual
that's his actual face I'm so sorry
Ethan oh [__] I wish I was more
beautiful what can I do this is the face
I was born with there's got to be a
better way
God damn look at that ugly mug [__] me
dude okay I got to do something about
this I need to go see Dr Kim he'll know
what to
do
hello good afternoon hi can I help you
can you help me what are you talking
about Ethan what happened what are you
talking about why are you looking at me
like that I have done nothing to my face
I didn't okay I have done no work on my
face Dan yeah okay that that that
explains it I understand that you're
anxious being around someone this hot
but you're going to have to get over it
and now that I'm hot like 9 out of 10
maybe 10 out of 10 the interior me is
still the same okay yeah of course of
course all right yeah I'm sorry all
right found it bro nice to see you good
to see you good morning everybody nice
to see you all morning you all good oh
my
[Music]
god well happen are you okay do you need
me to call medical attention does that
hurt I'm fine you guys are tripping d i
I don't know what y'all are talking
about stop looking at me okay I've had
no work done I've done nothing okay I've
been doing Kegel and other cheek
exercises kles with your it it's
connects it's a cheat thing you don't
understand so you like how you look what
do you mean by that do I ask you how do
you like how you look when you look in
the mirror I don't look like that Zach
what's up you look awesome dude you look
20 years younger That's my boy right
there thank you I've been doing
Kegel looking
great very good is that the Dior lip oil
it is how did you that's what it is I
knew I knew as soon as you walked in
Olivia what's up any power points in the
works not today what's what's different
yeah I don't know it's a good hair day I
guess love hey what's good baby what we
eating for lunch brother I don't know
dude I don't know if I'm that hungry
anymore all right well let me know when
you're hungry okay yeah buddy sure sure
dude what's up cam what are you working
on just you know drawing some cool
monsters and stuff oh dude that's sick
it's a whole book of monsters right yeah
actually can you stay there you look
pretty inspiring today you're not
drawing in that book though why not
you're you're a work of art okay
yeah go
ahead
man how did they notice that I got work
done I thought it was so subtle it looks
so natural I need to go back to Dr Kim
to do try this again to get it perfect
I'm going to do
that well here it is
oh you look Gorgie oh my god wow for
real thank you Dr Kim we love he's a
mirow worker I've I seriously look like
at least 20 years younger literally at
touch it wow yeah wow touch it go ahead
I was touching it earlier it's
interesting it doesn't it doesn't feel
like skin it's weird I don't think it is
actually I think it was uh is it skin it
it feel some other material that they've
that they used for that cuz they they
get rid of so much skin there's really
none left huh god wow but you guys you
know and and by the way it was only like
$200 so 200 it's a very affordable
option oh W turn into beautiful world
how did your lipstick transfer to your
hand like that you keep doing that
whoa oh no oh my godo you look amazing
oh I love have you been to Dr
Kim um maybe you know Natural Beauty
look like
aing a
br thank you so much talk to me
baby I mean I just ask for like a
natural look just we just did like a
tiny bit of of a buckle
removal God I love that yeah right we
did one tiny procedure we just took a
little Buckle fat up that's cool that's
cool yeah glad you're so so willing to
talk about it so open about it it's
really results are hard to hard to argue
with oh my God so there it is everybody
we're back we're shooting sketches now
you understand what I'm saying you
understand people say where's my
membership money go to today huge
budget production yeah big budget stuff
here plasic cery plastic surgery ain't
cheap by the
ways Sam got me good cuz she she did the
Prosthetics and she put all this glue on
my face and then before it was time to
remove it she's like I got to go but
here's the
here's the stuff to remove about I don't
know what I'm doing it was so [__] oh
my god there was so much [__] glued on
my face and I was just scrubbing there
was like oil and alcohol and all this
crazy [__] I didn't know what was at um
and I was just scrubbing my skin was
like turning red whole crazy I had glue
stuck in my
beard it's horrible we got a lot of it
in the behind the scenes of you trying
to get it
off oh
there end of the episode today episode
thank you AB behind the scenes is back
uh but Lena and Olivia were uh saviors
you guys help me out thank you nice
anytime
anytime should we try the and brother
and Son oh yes I had to move because of
D he told me this is the um the
Valentine's Day collection so
Valentine's
Day you know still not being
aiac effect on on y'all little viag
there oh those are nice looking this
chocolate box dud oh this is all of them
so here take one yeah here
love let's
see now I'll say oh AB you may want this
the Anton's is very expensive and I saw
people some people saying I mean so a
lot of people love it but some people
saying
M so I just want to say first of all I
have no vested interest in you buying
any of this so like if you don't want to
spend a shitload of money on chocolate
just know that some people didn't think
it was worth
it right I
mean okay I I just a disclaimer like if
you're like damn I really want to try
that but I don't have a money just it's
probably not worth it with peace and
love to the Suns it's definitely a
luxury it's a luxury item uh for sure
that said had from them so far so cute
yeah it's good for like a birthday maybe
kind ofe deal it's like a bottle of wine
or champagne it's like yeah you could
you could get the Two Buck Chuck right
see that's so cute with the heart salted
caramel let's go that's my
[__] theor one oh there there are two
you want to Strawberry champagne
strawberry champagne all different
flavors try the one with the hearts love
which one I want D that one you gave me
just now which is a new one I'm eating
it too [__] just it's such a um burn
almost like shred caramel in I wear
right salted caramel that's the one you
go for we both just had it and it's so
good if you like that it's not not
everybody likes salted caramel but I
love it this my shift dude the
strawberry champagne is so good mhm mhm
it that's jelly do you like the jelly I
like that one oh my God I don't know if
it was it wasn't jelly uhhuh didn't have
that chewy texture it was more like a
liquid Maybe I feel like mhm what else
we got in here he knows better than the
sery chili I mean
jelly popcorn there's a popcorn one wait
popcorn I'm slamming that right now so
[__] good oh I love but butter
popcorn the popcorn's so good dude oh
butter popcorn yeah let's share it good
idea you want to try it these things are
so heavy like
[Music]
yeah hm butter popcorn oh I like that
yeah that's refreshing that's fun that's
good M what else is in here mango white
Sesame strawberry champagne you
mentioned that one Macadamia lemon
mering coconut
almond uh striped hazelnut
gianda coconut want try the coconut one
then I'm out the popcorn one was really
good coconut what are you looking for
coconut there's one I really didn't like
what it tastes like inside of a men's
restroom what which one I want to try
what the [__] that's the only way I can
describe it what was which one was it
one was that it was the urinal cake
one it was P orange
guava uh Jeff just donated by the way
just Mark whatever don't and Son's Mark
Jeff Mark Jeff do we think that that's
really him or is that just you think so
yeah yo probably yo
he's just figuring it out listen Mark
Jeff with peace and love Apparently one
tastes like a urinal according to Zach
wait we need to try it it's the guava
which one was it oh he uh he became a
member
he oh that is him he did the $20 a month
membership he said oh my God we love you
he's a uh an absolute Legend I believe
is that cheer okay sorry Mike uh Jeff
Daniel Jeff Daniel love your work big
Jeff Daniel Mark Jeff so this one
apparently according to Zach tastes like
a men's restroom men's it's not a piss
taste it's like a fragrance like they'd
have in a men's rest this is Passion oh
okay well that's a big difference yeah
so it's you're you're
insane well that's that's true but you
know but not because of it yeah it's
good it's good mhm I didn't I didn't
like it pass maybe it smells like some
kind of perfume maybe it's invoking like
f Breeze yeah I can see that it's nice
and floral though it's good that's very
nice teodor would yeah he loves that
love teodor loves passion for
it I eat that man's restroom all day
different flavors all right thank you um
Mark Jeff it's always a pleasure I got
to meet the other brother by the way are
you good I know yeah is he cool yeah is
he weird
no not weird no The Vibes were okay yeah
you didn't ask about you didn't think
about asking him to leave no you're
talking about the other son I just
haven't met him before so I met him too
oh he's okay yeah he's seemed fine if
anything Mark Jeff is the weird one you
know he's the weird brother true just
kidding love you love it's funny cuz I
feel like the one that we've been
talking to is the one I haven't met the
one you've been wait what do you mean
where I met
Jeff yeah Jeff Mark Jeff but his brother
I haven't met and that's the guy we're
mostly been talking to oh I see I see
gotcha we met
him they came in last week yeah they St
by the studio was there a smell when he
was here like good chocolate it smelled
[__] dank dude like they had just
[__] ripped a fat blunt right before
walking in it was crazy that's that
Ambrose they're crazy like that all
right nice thank you Brothers Sons
always bringing the the chy yummy
goodness and I meant no disrespect by
tasting like FR bre I appreciate I
appreciate the honesty you know we got
to keep it real if they want if they
want me to lie they have to pay me right
right mean it's [__] nice to bring us
all this [__] but no disrespect it's all
up it's all it is a beautiful Box by the
way I mean it was an adventurous flavor
I'll give you that and not everybody
likes Citrus mixed with chocolate you
know maybe that's just not for you yeah
yeah um all righty all right we got to
talk about both of the things in our
title before it gets too late is that
right and Ben Shapiro and Ben Shapiro
all right let's do that then death Jews
death to Israel easy dude whoa Ben he's
gone off the deep end he's he's actually
switched teams that's right he's
actually he says I'm going I've decided
that Hamas is my calling he's joining
our death to
America
oh
man uh which one you want to do David
dubri let's do dub du let me see where
is that dang
[Music]
thing here so Jason
Nash as everybody knows by
now has gained a reputation
for and I mean this with all With all
sincerity and I mean this in the meanest
un meanest way possible only with PE and
love like I don't I'm not trying to make
a like this dude is at Rock Bottom like
this dude is down bad and I do not want
to make him feel
worse he does
still he still lives in a mansion I
don't believe you I mean damn he's got
he's got a pretty young wife that was
basically Ben Affleck was interested in
that's said that believe oh oh he needs
toing girl right he needs to keep
providing why did you unmatch me nobody
wants to be married to a unemployed you
know loser and I'm not saying bottom
though he's got a he's got a house
relationship yeah newly
wed can't pay his mortgage he has
Winner's attitude you know what I'm
saying yeah ninja that Tyler well anyway
uh I'm happy for all his success that
being said everybody
knows him now uh
for begging for money on Tik Tok live
and really it is really a sight to see
and I M I've just been questioning David
as a as a friend as a
person I know he doesn't pay any of the
Vlog Squad members and they're all doing
their own thing but of all of them Jason
is the one that's been there with him
that's ridden with him and also who's
just just doesn't have much talent
beyond what they and I mean that with
all peace and
love he doesn't have much talent beyond
what David can use him
for I mean you could say that about
everybody know in the Vlog Squad you
couldn't say that about Jeff Whit
sure he not it was not in the Vlog Squad
already though but um oh that's an
interesting situation no ice on the
bottom like that thank you can I get a
little tidbit of that live on Tik Tok
cuz I haven't seen it yeah what
everybody's talking about yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's okay good here's Tana talking
about it recently and we'll we'll get
pull up clips of that but there's anyway
David made a comment about it that's
what this is all leading to and it's you
know can someone make Jason Nash a
[__] door Dash account if I open my
Tik Tok one more time to seeing him
begging for roses on my live for you
page I'm calling CPS have you seen your
kids have you seen them and also when
they go to school are their friends like
hey I saw your dad like begging for a
Galaxy like and I'm I know I'm a sellout
okay I'm not against people doing things
for money but at this point it's like I
would rather see him behind a pay wall
cheeked up like I just I just don't get
I just every single time I've opened my
phone Jason Nash is on live begging for
money and I want answers have you seen
your kids this month that that part I
don't I don't agree with and I don't get
yeah because everybody's got to work
people will say that to me whenever I'll
post like a photo shoot or something and
they're like go be with your kids it's
like I am with my kids shut up
everybody's work I also work I do stuff
welcome to the modern world so it's a
little sensitive spot as a parent to
hear somebody say that're being real
about that aspect whatever he's doing
probably enables him to have more time
with his kids if anything kids are
probably trying to get away from him
right exactly but she's so funny but
that was a very funny delivery yeah it
was
good um so there's a phenomenon on Tik
Tok live battles they're essentially
real-time competitions between two
streamers where the winner is decided by
the viewers decided by who gets the most
money from sticker donations and stuff
like that let me see do we have
um do we
have I clips of him competing uh yeah
one second and it's like he's he's doing
this all the time really like this is
his full-time job and you can even hear
him talking about it he's like I have to
he's doing this to pay his bills quote
unquote I just think the other thing too
is like you have children so it's like
that's the thing too I think a lot of
people don't realize that it's like you
have kids and I you know you you need to
support your children somehow 100% I I
literally would do only fans to support
my kids wait wait when I do anything
like like I don't know I love he's like
listen I got to go live and beg for my I
have to do
something well here's the question do we
I
mean is he making a decent amount of
money doing this I have no idea but I
can't imagine it's very good so it's got
to be like close to minimum wage he
talks about Tik Tok help helping him out
like they offered him some sort of deal
the same way Snapchat does oh my God
they he got a contract and they're like
paying him to do this that's kind of
different that's different than like
doing it making barely minimum wage at
which point just go go apply for a job
at Home Depot man like just get a real
job yeah it must be more than that yeah
cuz he has a very expensive house like a
but he's saying he can't afford it
anymore right but it's like super
expensive how much how much was it I
don't it's like a very big house in La
let me see I mean that's expensive
regardless
ofas house having kids in general was so
expensive um his house oh 1.3 million I
mean that seems reasonable and with what
he's been through yeah he could after
his whole career if he can't afford a
$1.3 million house with the exposure and
all the [__] that he's done with David
who's like a multi multi
multi-millionaire that's [__] up in my
opinion no I I agree with your point I
know it's a lot of money right I'm not
saying it's not but y'all dve if David
is worth like 50 million plus do and
Jason can't afford his
mortgage you know anyway here you said
earlier somebody said um why does he
just get a door Dash whatever right like
do you ever think about going at to Door
Dash to like a you know did you ever
think about going back to like any other
job or like or just like I love Yeah
electrician obviously you do lives with
him um I don't know just I just never
thought it's like it's like it's
entertainment or nothing I don't care
what it is this the question that every
YouTuber never wants to hear ever this
is the question why don't you just do
something when are you need to go apply
for a job somewhere MH you're this is no
longer a viable career option for
you it's
honestly probably why a lot of people
when they're up will go into like
investing in creating their own product
or a brand absolutely something because
you kind of have to
prepare yourself for that day to come I
can't imagine there's much and have
something else you can do you got to be
ready you got to prepare for that day
because the thing is there's got to be
nothing worse than being famous and
broke right imagine seeing Jason Nash
like you know bag and groceries not that
that's not an admirable job but imagine
every day people being like holy [__] is
Jason Ash dude you're bagging groceries
what the [__] what are you doing here
that would be rough just non-stop
everyday humili
but it seems like that's what he's
already getting just for doing Tik Tok
live which I I still haven't seen those
but we're going to I'll show you I'm
going to show you I sent one they do no
no I'm
no it's just
a I'm genuinely asking cuz anytime I see
one the comments are like why doesn't he
like work like a real job like this
isn't me saying this as a negative thing
I'm just totally this guy's kind of wild
for this question but I appreciate it
he's like bro everybody's telling you
that you need to get a job does he
answer I'm curious he does why don't I
get a real
job no no no not to be offend but why
don't you give up no that's that's
really not I'm genuinely asking because
it's the comments I see I know why you
do it yeah but like say that is okay you
know what just Flav like that why don't
you get a real job uh I don't have any
skills okay that's the boogie that's the
Boogie excuse right right he literally
SS the same thing Hold On Boogie do you
have advice for Jason let's say he goes
to a recruiter I did work at a small
gaming store back in okay I could say
that6 I am disabled uh recognized by the
state of Arkansas but also un States
govern there's that downside of that is
I am extremely depressed so there's some
mental health issues that we bring to
the table and then physically I I am
morbidly obese I have no
references no
orry no education and when you Google my
name you might see rumors that I beat my
ex-wife should men I'm also a
fellow whoa no Jason you don't have to
say
that about two
years yeah honestly it sounds like
Jason's got it
Izzy compared to Boogie Yeah well yeah
Boogie is kind of in a world of his own
Jason's AV Able Body able mind you know
I'm ready to send his ass to the front
line boy can you hold a gun can you
march time to fight for Freedom
somewhere I don't see that's why someone
someone said that the other day why
don't you get into real estate I'm like
I hate it I don't have a real Bo granny
name do you have any interest um outside
of entertainment um no okay I mean
golfer I can't golf I mean do you know
how humiliating this is that he went on
this podast he's probably doing these
guys a favor and now they're they're
having an intervention where they're all
suggesting different professions he
could uh potentially exit
into you know like this guy's coming on
here to promote his entertainment
career what what's left of it and people
are like you got to hang it up wait is
this not this is his podcast on his
channel oh it is on his channel I feel
like he well there it is 13,000 views in
four days that man needs to go to
[__]
he need to go to the
recruiter I feel like he wanted to
address it and he may have even pred him
to ask him yeah yeah that's possible he
uploaded this on his channel
[__] he has ads 13,000 views and
seek gigs paying
him but I see this happen all the time
what the [__] like I see it on
housewives somebody will get a divorce
and then it's for the first time in
their life they're on their own mhm so
it's like David Mama they go and figure
out a new career and they you have to
put some work and you got to choose
maybe study something if you real estate
is something you could study and go do
in like a year it's not that difficult
to get into it
um it's possible it's possible to to
kick off something you can Crush in real
estate and with his reputation he might
be able to recruit some some clientele
right out the you know people might get
a kick out of working with him well
celebrity uh yeah real
estate what would I what would I
do I was about to say live stream it but
no never mind I hope that didn't come
off as like these guys apparent these
they know him these are like his friends
he does a show with so if anybody knows
how down bad he is it's them if he if
they know how they're the ones that
would know how dire his situation is and
so when they're like you need to get a
[__] another job then you know shit's
crazy
crazy a negative thing I was ask I like
what you're doing you're you're posing
the question of what everyone's thinking
which is
good what if he you're saying what is on
everybody's mind I'm well I saw I saw
comments like I'm going to ask him
because people are you know I don't know
I just see it as straight talking Zack
you know yeah straight they got to split
the I mean this revenue's getting split
four ways with 13,000 views are they
guested I can't tell what's happening
actually I have no idea how much okay
it's like 50 bucks he said it I mean I
don't know if you passed it how much he
makes on a live probably yeah he said
it's not profitable yet he said he's
hoping by next year it will be a year
yeah oh my
God I don't um maybe we can keep it
floating with the Tik Tok money it again
I I just don't look at it my opinion on
all of this depends on how much he's
making from this Tik thing mhm like yeah
it's kind of embarrassing to be begging
for money on Tik Tok but if he's making
you know a couple Grand a day doing no
way okay no shot I I have no idea in the
beginning there are people that can pull
crazy numbers but he's doing it every
day there's return diminishing returns
big time there's nobody left bro I saw
him on live with like a hundred [__]
viewers begging for money from a 100
transient Tik Tok scrollers
okay
do what you got to do I guess and again
I'm not if this was anybody I would I
you know I love the hustle appreciate
the hustle it's the fact that David do
this man's supposed best friend threw
him out like a used tampon is that okay
to say or is that
chauvinistic I mean you do throw away
tampons when you're done using them yeah
I don't feel like that's like a used
baby wipe is more G you could say it
about anything I don't know why I like
use tampon I like it it's so vulgar and
graphic vag are dis pretty gross if
you're going gross female vaginas are
dis look at it like go ahead what female
vaginas are
disgusting was that myin who said that
that is myin man he is totally straight
a lot going on Psy [__] Halo somebody
called breakfast burrito which I love
what a great name said oh that's their
name no that's just their
username said offer him a deal he can
spill the tea about David
interesting Jason I'll hire you and I'll
pay you a good
salary whatever you're making from your
podcast and Tik Tok live I'll double
it assuming it's not a lot which I don't
think it
is contact let's talk but with the
condition that you sell out your best
friend best quote unquote best friend
yeah you have to sell you have to sell
them out all the secrets basically be
humili already know everything yeah what
know [__] Jason knows [__] also you're
going to have to wear a um he's live
right now people say oh give me the link
you're going to have to wear a chicken
suit and we will occasionally drop
buckets of tar on
you ooh Riley said Jason is worse than a
used tampon at least the tampon
worked
[Music]
oh
[__]
dude discarded like a defective
tampon true that's a good point actually
I I okay I'm G to open this link because
I'm curious but guys do not I'm not
please don't go harass him this is not
what I'm trying to do this is not what I
want to happen I'm just genuinely
curious oh he's got a th people watching
he's doing it right now Eli here this is
the perfect okay let me see you're
private but you're not showing up is
this about he's always in his kitchen
okay you can't see so people come on
random people I don't know if the the
competition has started yet it has it
doesn't work on desktop oh no it
has so at the top there's like a number
okay but you can see all the presents
he's got here like a don't how much are
these worth like that's what stuff you
can give oh that's what I can
give he has 2,300 coins right now I'll
find out that cannot be a lot of money
no it's like 10 bucks I think I think
it's less 10 bucks I think a point is a
cent it seems to be 10 bucks according
to this calculator here
okay so he's in his
[Music]
um with the [__] the hat and
[__] you know Trisha's watching this
with like all the pleasure in the
world currency is so weird 66 coins is
$10 okay so he's got 2,000 it says he's
only been live for 18 minutes so in 18
minutes he's
made 30 bucks I've seen him get 5,000
coins the past 10
minutes he's gotten 5,000 more no I've
been watching for 10 minutes that's
that's $25 you get home cuz they take
70% is $25 AB it sounds like you said it
$25 and 10 minutes I think by love is
saying they're taking 7% but it's not
like eight hours a day it's not like a
normal I thought that's what he did I
don't think he's you can't do this for
oh God see I don't want you guys to say
all that Ethan's watching I'm not trying
to get into not trying to make course
that was going to happen I know I'm not
trying to make him feel bad or anything
$25 every 10 minutes is $150 an hour
okay but that is a good money if you're
doing like full-time
work also he a mortgage on a $1.2
million
house all right let's get off it we love
Jason and um I no disres I don't want to
I don't want to disturb him in his in
his
workplace I just genuinely curious to
see it it's interesting that we got to
see it live when we were talking about
it okay 660 coins is 10 bucks yeah and
then Tik Tok takes 70% that's crazy
70% why do people use this platform form
yeah I don't know why should you give
70% wait they keep 70% yeah yeah yeah
what that's crazy also they don't allow
you to take out more than 100 bucks a
day you know they have like this super
Advanced system oh so he's not making
more than1 wait that's not true I've
taken out more than that yeah you but
for people who don't make you need to
take it's super bizarre I've looked into
it I have
like more than $ thousand dollars on Tik
Tok I can't withdraw it why cuz I don't
make enough so a th you got to make more
to withdraw more dude Tik Tok is a
[__] scam what the hell that sounds
like a scam I can't emphasize how much
this web this Jason you're being used
Again by you better deal with David
right wait they take
70% so you spend 10 bucks and then you
have $3 to give to somebody that's ridic
you give 10 bucks and Tik Tok keeps yeah
well pretty
much no way do you hear him no is he
talking about me I donated a whale and
he started screaming my name how much is
a whale it's so weird that's what I was
trying to figure out it kept telling me
exchange exchange and like try and trick
you so you don't he really liked it I
have a um psychotic wait I have a bunch
of coins on mine remember Zach when I
was donating you bunch he gave me like a
100 bucks it was awesome thank you again
yeah I don't know what I don't know how
I got him I think I oh we we used to go
live remember no you did the NPC thing
oh yeah the N yeah we were live for so
much so people were donating okay and so
I converted it all into coins like I'll
go in there and I'll just do song
requests and [__] which is like you know
it's cool like you know some what let me
music you know let me see how much coins
I have and if I can go support Jason
financially try to withdraw it you're
not going to be able to no I think I
already invested it in coins is it
investment it's going to pay off for me
yeah I have 23 I'm still holding on to
my foa coins so I I have $1,100 on Tik
Tok and daily withdrawal limit is
$100 dude that's nuts that's funny wait
where do I see my
money hey
hey yeah the way he just reacted makes
me very afraid how about how much I just
spent oh you don't know how much you
spent it literally kept saying convert
to coins convert and then it just didn't
give me like a final Oh I thought that's
what I just spent love you scared the
[__] out of me love just sent a
screenshot of like yeah I thought that
was what I just $25 for a while so I
have oh 25 thank you I have
$1,833 I'm going to convert it it's it's
telling me to pay I don't want to pay it
out though this says I can take it all
out right
now it says minimum $10 yeah a minimum
$10 mine that's not maximum that's
minimum yeah minimum well maybe because
you're verified or something I don't
know you think so check on the okay yo I
can
buy I can buy 181,000
coins save 30% as no service fee
applies are you sure they take 70% that
seems
like unreal they
do
what well I mean maybe they changed it I
don't know they definitely did at some
point I mean I feel like I got to go I
got to make it rain on Jason right now
let's do it yeah I got I have
181,000
coins all right I'm exchanging that [__]
they didn't even go are you sure they're
like thank you I know it's so weird so
wait how much did you end up um so Zach
said it's like $25 oh so he stoked on
that all right so here's what I want
we're going to open it now that I'm
about to make it rain on him okay you
got to do it quick because he's gonna
play music what like because when I did
it Journey was playing in the background
he just got in with a new person so
there's no music playing yet oh [__]
okay was it a good Journey
song yeah all right
Jason I know David ain't paying you so
don't know how to act let me pay let me
help you out foring weights or your
workout program or you know I know
you're into that you know this is my
daughter was calling I had to take it
I'm so sorry all right so how do I do
this I like your lemons
you're let me a crazy one real fresh
tonight the craziest one I can fine yeah
yeah yeah bye all right I'll see you in
a sec hold on this one's 25,000 Adam's
dream yo look at
that thank
you you guys can't see it
Sierra oh my God Ethan Klein
26,000
wow a universe from Ethan
k6000 oh wow Ethan Klein H Street thank
you Ethan it's very very nice watch I'm
going to send another one he's going to
freak out I'm sending another one $15 a
mon that's nice I don't know if it's a
troll or if it's uh no it comes in
kindness I'm not sure Ethan
again
wow holy [__] another one let's send
another one I have 180,000 points [__] a
third one come on let's Go's hey man
thank you for the Galax Ethan I've never
seen that gift before yeah cuz it's
insane who the [__] would spend getting
I'm seeing the one I bought was
$44 oh my God that [__] gift is sick
yeah it's so I think this has got to be
the most expensive one ever you know I
don't even know what that gift is called
cuz I've never gotten it before I'm
going to send ites any know what that
gift is called a GI that's four times
dude we're going to space in this [__]
it shows an astronaut riding a rocket
into space Oh my God Ethan Jesus I don't
you don't have to do that okay oh that
[__] sick how much coins do I have
left I just spent a lot of coins 77,000
left he's in a competition with this
girl so she's just getting Crush oh
they're getting
comp What's happen so what's the um
getting absolutely you just Spirit
bombed this girl out of the [__]
competition oh wait there's more
expensive ones
40,000 45 what the like there shouldn't
even be options to go that P I'm not
done Jason uh talking about how nice
this is it is nice what it was I mean
I'm giving him 2,000 bucks you know
that's a lot of money, bucks are you
yeah oh my God but Tik Tok has
70% oh right got musicing so really
you've given him 500 bucks
after I had $1,800 from our live we just
did these Goofs so I converted into
coins and he's got to mute the music man
oh can you guys tell him to mute the
music [__] ACDC BL well this girl's
almost eliminated so I think few more
donations knockout punch I'm trying to
find a one to get which one should I
give him fall candles Ferris wheel I
want to take him on the ferris wheel for
some
kisses I wish you guys could see
it I have it yeah I have it on my
phone
yeah just went away what's the score AB
you see the red on
top blurry the red on top is is his
score compared to the
blue let's see maybe I'll wait for his
next competition this girl's crushed
this girl's [__] KO look how look how
like dominated she is she like
damn so wait what's the score I still
can't okay see the red on top compared
to the blue the red is him okay oh so
she loses oh yeah yeah [__] losers
how much does she have 20 this may be
the worst loss in Tik Tok battle history
here I'm going to
send H what should I send why is there
no like dicks or something
fun it's all boring [__] cut my nails
last night but for real though there
there are options here how about proud
of me I'm I have my arm stabilized at
Dan Dan said he's so proud of how stable
my hand is Dr steady hands yo so the
most expensive one on here that I can
see is
uh here these ones are
crazy all right he muted it so I'm on H3
now is that is that what I'm being told
because somebody type that here I guess
I'll look so I'm going to drop a gold
mine H3 am I being made fun of on H3
right now we're hooking you oh yeah in
the thumbnail oh boy oh
boy well hello A3 how are you thank you
Ethan I'm just send I'm making it rain
poor van has no
idea love dude I'm making it rain right
now thank you Ethan for the yes thank
you she doesn't understand crazy she
doesn't understand
AR yeah W I'm sorry David is rushing to
his house 200 miles hour right now get
off the [__] phone Jason let's thank
everybody Ethan gets the booster Ethan
you got a boosting glove so if you want
to stick around wait what
is you want to stick for the next game
conratulations
SK let's knock her
Maggie we and Evan let's get some
fireworks going than you guys I'm I'm so
sorry it's uh I think no no no no no I'm
not I'm not mad I don't I won't ever get
mad I'm just confused everyone's telling
me I'm on some podcast I have anxiety
we're on podcast right now so I'm
sending them nonstop I don't know he
here now they should show up now these
are all me I'm sending if it'll be good
for you send a car you sure
see I'm sending fireworks really big
podcast a podcast that's like episod so
more fireworks I'm sending a
dinosaur I know I know I know oh man mys
went up I love the I'm sending um a good
afternoon guys we're daily 80 and we oh
my God we just broke the top 80 because
of Ethan
Klein all right Ethan I don't know if
may you know how to we don't know what
that means but we're happy for you buddy
happy Friday I mean what's a happy
Friday
sticker recorded when you said my name
it perfectly here's a whale we might as
well see if we can get into ring love a
whale thank you Ethan for the happy
Friday there's the whale can they hear
me yeah I can hear you he you want
something I don't know sorry whale this
is the Jason
fun the no sorry this is the Jason he
needs girl he deserved it oh meteor show
in the top 100 which is really nice of
you thank you so
much 40,000 people looking at me no big
deal yeah you see the fireworks where
are they I guess Ben Shapiro dropped a
rap song all right I'm sending a
jellyfish that's true we're going to
watch
thaty oh Jason you
want thanks for the plug bro watermelon
thank you Ethan thank you for the
aquarium or whatever that one's called
I'm sending um how are you a
championship trophy you got what are you
talking about I'm fine don't I'm not
good Under
Pressure this is quite quite an I can't
tell you enough I sentes not happen for
me ever I sent like 120,000 when we
started let me see see if I can see him
I don't want to burn through him God I
think he's got a troll account over here
travel it's real money girl you could
spend that money account I mean he might
be trolling or he might be he's got 1.8
million that's
him it's a different account what girl
are you talking it's real
money you so much she's cing sorry girl
I'm sending an epic GG to fle fastic I
look
I just sent an epic GG to flex thank
you 2300 Ethan with the good game or I
used to call it gang
gang sending
flowers how do I put stuff on how do I
do that uh it's it's certain ones like
the cowboy hat we hit $7 I think they
the cheaper ones go oh there cheaper
ones dude this crazy I spent like like
$500 and it's like a gift for like two
seconds I should dominate the screen
Mr orange what is this is it going to
turn him into Orange um oh my God there
is so many thank you so much for the
follow sunglasses oh my God that's
embarrassing we need a good one after
sunglasses yeah sunglasses there go it's
not going
on say oh that's the there it
is how about a crown how about I just
keep the crown on his head okay I'm
going to send like 10 I'm going to send
a bunch of crowns thank you NES followed
I'm sending So Many Crowns know is this
exciting this is fun
right all right I just sent like 20
crowns Thank you Lisa with the
Galaxy this cuz normally Vanna beats me
let's send some Autumn Leaves what yeah
yeah it's true I think Jason's just like
tripping out yeah I'll take this moment
if I'm on H stre go
follow what he say son's B is that he
say thank
you it's my son's the glove
Ator in but I think this
m you're welcome for the Crown King you
dropped this take this opportunity to uh
show Ethan's audience the goal is yeah
show me actually no Mo Guys it's okay I
don't care about Los listenit why are
people so worried battles are all about
supporting creators it's
totally
not to get mad Lisa thank you Lisa thank
you
nightmare
hang
nightm this galaxy one's sick I'm going
to send a
Galaxy nightmare Klein thank you Mo I
appreciate you guys yes the lion one is
really cool too sucker um oh my God God
they need better options for the Galaxy
you're welcome here she rabbit I just
sent a rabbit
guys
everyone thank you Mel ice GI I've never
seen thank you he's never seen these
ones did he show us the son's oh [__] I
sent him the podium that one was
[Music]
20,000 G is it
over no she's still fighting this is
this is kind of amazing sort of like a
modern day Rocky iore I want to see the
score game Justin MVP
Justin for all that love thank you Lisa
r m
Gary
Richard want to drop his glove yeah we
got to see you guys got to see the here
this one's lemonade I bet never seen
this one Ethan thank you for the tiny
diny you're welcome my brothering I got
you tiny D all day check the lemonade b
a lemonade that's right tiny tiny how
about fall candles you ever seen this
one now look at this [__] we are 62nd in
the country when we started this match I
wasn't even in the top 100 well so
that's really good even with the fall
candle y Here Comes The Blowfish that
was big in October but now
it's going through true St going through
the uh I don't even know what that one
is how about the rhythmic bear love dony
thank you Carol thank you John thank you
so much I apprciate oh yeah this one's
good you guys will like this
one good games Jason game oh there's the
dancing bear from Ethan yeah let's see
how many points Ethan has
accumulated 168,000 points nice oh my
God have a great all hold on let me just
bust my load and then we we we can go
let me look I have 12 it's over wait he
left bro I'm not done giving you [__]
okay's next she was done okay
next Jason I'm currently getting a cover
up tattoo right now and I thought let
get this part start batt Jason Nash
right now let's go baby you're going to
love it Jason thinks I'm never running
yesterday when you went to top 41 in 40
minutes I do I do remember that I'm glad
you remember it too I remember why are
people giving them this is River from
Calabasas River you're catching us at an
interesting time all right God top the
screen again I'm back with the gang gang
I'm chasing you dude take my money Ethan
Klein what that CH can we beat
I
know crazy the other day Dar man was
here I have
6,000 with the astronaut on was Ethan
Klein sniping against me I don't know no
it's it's not about podcast right now
they take it so serious podcast like I'm
so sorry
go let's go right
now let's [__] go right
now send him the car I love his
excitement it makes me feel good when I
send it oh my God
to something let's bust out something
here embarassing for
Us's here we Jason's H right now if
anybody does this well it is Jason Nash
I just sent
[__] something this is bad oh this guy's
getting [__] actually fun watching
the other person get
destroyed eth confetti I'm going to put
another 10,000 my own money here like no
I'm Kidd he might he might he's never
dropped a line in his life that's why
he's 25 no he dropped like four
universes already four universes bro
that's how they gauge
money you ready I'm about to drop
mystery firework 2000 and then I'm
pretty much out what the hell is this
bro he's going to lose his mind look at
this music's coming
back Ethan with the fireworks be kind to
yourself though that's a good message I
did not send that one for the May is
here um Foodies No Cap good afternoon
I'm almost out of money sorry I haven't
been thanking
everybody we can snipe this chat we can
snipe this do we have a glove does
anyone have a glove bro you're done
don't even
try all right let's see here's uh travel
with you thank you for being here today
I really appreciate it it's always fun
on Tik
Tok 3,000 people the
I see you e CL with the TR with me WEA
man 41,000 people watching you can cook
this and then here I can send that we
can figure this out oh I can laser thank
you Ethan if he doesn't drop a uni I'm
going to be
disappointed he h he already dropped
four now spent $1,800 he might be done
with the bit 2,000 in the live guys
incredible don't that's Friday baby
thank you so much that's how we do it
around here and don't forget to follow
me up here and follow River too
I don't remember what he said but check
out his son's band that's cool that's
good dad that's good
dading all right
well God I wish I had more money it was
so fun I want to keep that was so fun I
love throwing money to to a pan
handlers see that's not nice no that's
mean I mean it is virtual pan handling
though right I think literally right it
is literally yeah it's literally you
know like when we were pull when we were
driving to work there was a dude who was
pan handling in the road with the sign
right I would have if he had a Tik Tok
account I would have given him some
roses and
stuff you should get on Tik Tok but I
you know what I mean you missed up yeah
next time I'll ask do you have Tik Tok
I'll send you some roses
brother oh man that was fun
that was a
rush that was so fun we love you
Jason oh this is the thumbnail he saw of
himself that's confusing I can see why
what is that yeah I don't what just
because of the tongue thing cam oh he
smiles with the
tongue yeah yeah yeah
exactly all right good luck out there
Jason have a great Friday buddy
if Dave is not paying you I sure as H
will he's probably richer than me too I
I would
assume Chad kept saying you had some
kind of glove I kept saying use the
glove I have a glove wait what does that
mean I got a glove I know what it means
like a finishing move maybe I don't know
you know what I mean I did spend a lot
of [__]
money send I can send a wait you know
what I mean no it's asking me to
recharge H what's a glove you guys I
want to send a
glove it's not a
gift we could save it for
another no I want it no Jason I want the
glove I'm a gifter level 25 you guys I
think that's the top level
maybe oh man well if you find out what's
the glove let me know yeah I look into
it and I'll come back for you J
JJ we're dogs
now oh here it is boosting glove what
does that do
boosted grants up to 20 30% chance of
triggering times five points
no that would have been crazy if I use
that oh D I have three of them save it
oh [__] save it till tomorrow or live on
Monday we'll have to do a live so we can
accumulate a bunch of coins again sure
they send it to me so I send it to him
MH essentially oh man the booster 30%
chance to trigger times five dude he's
about to
retire
H
sucks breaks my
heart um well that was
exciting good
[__] he's going to get his he's going to
be able to pay his mortgage this month
yeah
which is a
relief a big
relief all right where were we so that's
what he does we were going to show David
right so here he is
um David recently went to check on
him as he heard about his reputation for
you know doing these Tik Tock lives and
people were talking so David being the
good friend the good caretaker that he
is uh he went to visit him so here's
this I like to visit him at least once a
week just to make sure that he's alive I
know that he's doing Tik Tok live every
day now but I'm still not convinced it's
him it could be AI at this
point
Jason oh my God I thought you were W I
got so freaks out cuz you haven't seen
him in a while yeah live streaming I was
and then it wasn't going well so I got
off dude you're kind of becoming a
legend on Tik Tok now I know not not in
a good way yeah but I think it's fun not
this [__] showed up in a goddamn
Crown to laugh at him being a tick tock
quote Legend I mean
listen I can make fun of the guy I'm not
responsible for him this is tasteless
yeah this is just
mean dude David do sucks he is such a
douche people still watch him that's
nuts to me I I've seen Tik toks like
take a shot every time Jason nashes onl
you haven't come over in like a little
bit and I called Joe and I was like is
Jason doing okay and Joe's like I
haven't seen him on live in a while and
I go how long has it been he's like
hours and that's that's that's when we
start to worry when you haven't been on
because he needs to work bro why is that
funny like come on it's not funny let's
get a Jason fun going we need to get the
need to get a
count I know but I'm not responsible for
him I don't go to his house in a crown
and like what is David Dober he drives
like a Aston Martin or some [__] shows
up in his Aston Martin and the crown
jewels to go [__] tap dance on his
best friend's dead career
you just got back from like a Christmas
dinner why are you dressing so nice well
you do better on Tik Tok live when you
look nice is that true yeah where did
you get that stat that you do better on
Tik Tok live is that just from testing
no someone told me that wait really I
met this live streamer he's a really
nice guy he was like Hey Little tip like
when you dress nice you'll do better and
I I can't tell you that this really
makes me sad he goes I need to dress
nice I get more donations like he's a
[__] door too Mormon or some [__]
like damn bro come on you don't have to
wear that turtleneck you don't you
shouldn't have to wear that turtleneck
not if you don't want to it he's being
forced to wear a turtleneck now that's
not right but if he wants to it looks
good yeah he he don't he does it because
he wants donations right and which is
where the problem lies you're right
you're right also yeah uh yeah of course
uh uh no I don't whatever makes and then
I tried it out but then again I didn't
make any money today so bye guys thanks
for having us over in your bye guys in
your little hobbit home dude can't even
afford a whole door
man like David how are you just going to
wave goodbye like that come
on poor guy now home we moved to the sh
dude I'm a bit curious cuz he was
sitting in a pretty nice car there too I
couldn't tell what kind of car was it
was a lucid air I think one of those new
Lucid no he's driving a lucid
I I cuz that's like 100,000 plus car I
think it's even more than that I think I
recognize steering wheel okay let me see
again the if he's driving a lucid then
then like what the [__] I want my money
back yeah me too I thought he'd be in
like a Camry like 9 85
Camry when we start to worry when you
haven't been on you look like you just
got back from like a Christmas dinner
why you dressing so nice why you do
better um David's car that's definely
there's no way he drives that he's lety
he got it Lucid that's that's there's no
way Jason can afford that how much is
that car I don't know they're yeah
they're super expensive they're like
super highend there's different models I
believe what's started at
75k oh but the start yeah that is
David's car you yeah okay so it's even
more of a
dick and he says come sit in my $100,000
car could it could be a gifted one as
well I mean true gifted yeah he gifts he
gifts all of his friends Cars mhm yeah
something tells me based on their
interaction and the way you know you
look like got back from like a Christmas
dinner why are you dressing so nice well
you do better on Tik Tok live when you
look nice is that true yeah he [__]
made him come out and look at his car
and get in the driver's
seat it's like the humili he needs to
humiliate him we don't know exactly yet
what is this situation I'm just saying
so I I found a video of David using a
lucid with the same color scheme there
it is so I think that has to good catch
though love yeah it's funny oh my God
yeah you have a Rolex you want to show
him or something try it let's see try it
on a little bit yeah you want to see how
you look in this Rolex
bro oh [__]
me oh
[__] where did did you get that stat
that you do better on Tik Tok live is
that just from testing no someone told
me that wait really oh
man
oh there's another one is this the same
one a fan page uploaded this in December
is that the same one yeah it's the same
one just showing the origin where it
came from guys I'm visiting Jason like
to visit him at least once a week make
sure that a Snapchat reupload that'd be
my guess I couldn't find a lot of
information on it someone put it on our
subreddit and I found that it was linked
to this people love
him like even this reupload gets Mega
views top comment so these These are
comments from December so this is before
this isn't even coming from me Jason is
straight up laughing through the pain as
David laughs in his face this is sad and
I feel like Jason's just trying to laugh
through the pain this is equivalent of a
former boss showing up to your new
employment after firing you and roasting
you for not getting paid enough they
don't even know that it probably that
that's d David's car you
know this beautiful new this is actually
so sad I guess okay so everybody sees it
if D was a real friend he would help bro
out cuz he stopped doing the podcast
knowing the money he would get and how
it maintains Jason's life oh yeah I
heard Jason saying they had this big
podcast together all right I heard you
guys talk about it and Jason was like I
missed the money you know you you got
to like you had this big thing that was
really important to him you got to keep
it flowing bro find a
way it's gross he sucks it is
gross how old is David do
now 27 27 old ass
loser David sitting on
multi-millionaires laughing at his
friends
ouch David's laughing at him for being
on live but David's job is literally
posting to his snap Snapchat story true
the only difference is you make money
doing a lot more money doing it mm David
is laughing but Hil Loki did that to
Jason David can you like help Jason out
like
damn the guy obviously needs money yeah
wow was Jason pretending he had to drive
somewhere so David would
leave Jason and all his friends helped
him become a millionaire now David
leaves them for
broke okay yeah everybody sees what we
see yeah um we got a little bit of a
donation here checking the we got a the
Discord oh wait what wait you're
someone's giving me my money back this
is from TI Tik Tock what it's from Tik
Tock $500 your money back peace and love
your money laundering agent what it's uh
our friend our Saudi V oh my god
dude that's funny members go up that
actually might be accurate that might be
how much is that a real money donation
yeah it's a real donation what that's
crazy [__] God God
crazy oh [__]
whoa thank
you thank you so much that's funny too
it's very funny thanks for the money
laundering appreciate
that but that actually might be how much
Jason actually got from me 500 from 1800
MH so I did get a refund thank you to
Tik Tok but I see two of them why is
that it's a bug she a bug okay that
double shows it yeah yeah cuz it's like
exactly the
same well there you go we love Jason
Nash folks I mean well we limited we
limit that we put an aster next to that
statement yeah you put an asterisk in a
footnote next to
that Tik Tok just donated 50 uh
memberships as well oh my God thank you
man the official Tik Tok account you
know I've been saying a lot of mean
things about Tik Tok but I feel like you
know I'm really it's really turning
around for you guys I'm understanding
I'm well you're just having a blast on
there oh 100 from Tik Tok yo I'm about
to I'm about to have a live competition
right now Jason get in here let's
compete somebody said Ethan's hair looks
like Austin MC broom so that's what I'm
saying of it's a broccoli
assassin you know
it it
doesn't
G come on thank you Tick Tock appreciate
that all right so the other one we need
to talk about is the um the bench P this
is will be our last or well probably our
last
story but um I've been really looking
forward to this and I've held off the
color of your of your booty hole so
thank you so Ben Shapiro put
out
he put out I'm trying to find out where
the [__] what number is it number one in
gops and
GS oh here it is he collaborated with
this dude Tom McDonald who I guess is
he's one of those magga rappers we've
talked about him before so he he has a
lot of followers on YouTube dude has
like he's probably the most popular of
these like kind of magga he's definitely
doing better than uh the dude with the
Minecraft beard right that almost
accidentally
well there's that other guy he's he's
he's
heavier uh yeah Target fasha
Joe bread
[Music]
Joys only he will bring us closer when
we fall to our
knees and he'll LIF us from the ground
so that everyone see oh Big Nick
so I'm looking at his his music videos
he had one from two years ago 38 million
views called fake woke hell yeah you
know what I'm gonna give them pay them
uh their dues before I get into this and
credit them for saying they did not
claim the
video which is shocking I got mad
respect for that thank you thank you for
letting us mock it really I mean that's
what it's all about genuinely I got mad
respect for that the same thing with um
a lot of the other Maga rappers never
[__] with us when we made fun of them
the uh the one I just played uh I had to
remove the background music yeah that
one was getting CL remember yeah fukasha
Joe mhm was I don't know if that was K
uh fukasha Joe that was um that was
Minecraft bearded guy that was M yeah
yeah that was like the rightwing Like We
are the world you're right exactly they
do they do collab a lot forha Joe and
Minecraft beard but I think that one was
a Minecraft beard Le project so this guy
um Tom McDonald yeah he seems to only do
uh Maga waps sheepel these are his top
ones sheepel American flags Superman
fake woke dirty money and his new one
that just dropped seven hours ago with
Ben Shapiro
facts now I'll be totally honest with
you guys when I saw this I was browsing
um
Twitter and I saw this and I didn't
spend a long time looking at it cuz I I
was like oh this is just a weird deep
fake I don't get it and I promise you I
did not I left it there may be some
deaking going on in parts of this video
I guess but as far as I can tell this is
this is co-signed by Benny boy and this
is like uh wait you don't think it's
him uh
I mean I did initially and then you said
that and then I was like gu it could be
it was just my I was in just disbelief
that this would never happen right that
was exactly I thought it was a deep F
yeah Olivia was also saying that um but
yeah he's tweeting it and stuff so even
regardless it's it's co-signed by bench
P I think it is Ben yeah no I think I
think so too it's the Maga white and
nerdy that's all I can say I'm white and
nerdy every once I'm white and nerdy
white and nerdy those hoodies are just
wait facts care about your feeling does
his tattoo say
hog uh it's real blurry so it's hard to
tell but it can does look like Hogs this
dude it says hog on his face he's a hog
all right hold on we got to we got to
see if that's what it
is so find a closeup of him Ben Shapiro
let's see what he had to say about it
this is the real deal my
friends does in fact say hog this man T
this man tattooed hog on his face he did
shabbat shalom from my hipop
household holy [__] thoughts oh my
God it's like West Borland if he left
limp Olivia what do we
think hot as
SpongeBob by the way you're catching for
that comment he said SpongeBob's kind of
hot that's not what I said that is
simply not what I said what did you say
no I said before all this happened
before I found out what a terrible guy
he was when he was on the top of the
Broadway World I was like wow who's this
guy who's got a Tony nomination yeah
that's all I said I don't you didn't say
any of that I
said different word implication but no
but I'm with you he's a strange looking
sometimes Strang looking dudes if they
got like that's hot sometimes cuz it's
like a blank slate in a way where it's
like if you like who he is and what he's
about you'll find him hot he's just
strange looking your mind doesn't know
what to make of it and he's talented guy
he's probably charismatic you know
Tapper well well said oh yeah nothing
hotter than a man who tap dances tap
solo yeah well said yep um so anyway
without further Ado let's hear it
facts Ben comes in about halfway through
by the way if you start to be like I'm
tired of
hearing only and they can't canel my cuz
I'm the biggest independent rapper in
the whole freaking world that's not true
by any metric within two seconds there's
only two genders we're we're right to
the point he's the biggest independent
rapper in the world I mean what I mean
that's just provably false wait he
already said there's two genders that
was like the second line out of his
mouth oh I missed it and then goes into
best rapper yeah here what they call me
offens controversial there's only two
genders boys and girls they canel my
there's only two genders boys and girls
girls why boys and girls look creep I
don't think of wom I think of adults
yeah you think I don't know what you
think about they boys that's facts dude
Tom spooky actually uh E40 is the uh
independent uh rapper Vol E40 this guy
ripped off e4's um music video you know
what I'm talking about yeah I'll show
you let me show you E40 choices you
can't show I'm not going to play it I'm
just going to show you the set we'll
mute it right yeah I love the I love
this song it's one of the my favorite
songs and the video is insane too he's
got all these hip-hop Legends co-signing
him and there's tons of
um TVs and [__] behind him SE here here
wait God damn
it God damn it here kind of get a good
shot so you can see that he ripped him
off he needs a clip of you cosigning him
in his next video oh
here yeah yeah so he's in this kind of
room with all these TVs and
[__] definitely
rip all right let's get let's go
facts freaking world the whole flipping
world the whole gosh down
world if every Caucasian a bigot I guess
every muslim's a terrorist every liberal
is right I don't want to talk to folks
who don't get it go
I feel like of all the things to rap
about this is the lest [__] this dude is
straight rapping about
um he says if all whites are racist all
Muslims are
terrorists every liberal is
right every that's the next line if
every Caucasian is a bigot I guess every
muslim's a terrorist every liberal is
right you have lyrics yeah it's Link in
the doct tap oh I want to pull those up
yeah I was hoping it had closed caption
but it's not there yet he's up on genius
dude he's a
genius that's awesome all right go
ahead the American flag remember when
people would hang they've been taken
down they all been replaced with blms or
a rainow br what world do you live in
people hang American flags still it's
only BML and rainbow Flags now in every
neighborhood across Amer
I see what are you talking about we live
in Liberal Los Angeles and I see
American flags all of the time all of
the I don't believe I've ever seen a BLM
flag from a residential house a BLM flag
yeah like maybe I've seen a rainbow
maybe like twice in my life mhm oh I see
like Pride Flags a decent amount but a
like is there even like a what is that
even a BLM flag yeah I don't know if
they have a flag I don't think they I
don't think they [__] with flags like
that they don't believe in
Flags indeed they don't believe in flags
are flags are uh ugly things you know
well flags are frankly for colonists
that's right I mean that's nationalism
baby that's the tool of the colon burn
all the flags so true leftists don't
believe in
Flags oh what somebody said he's
obsessed with you say stuff but he's
Canadian he is yeah I just fact
check no
wayer all these
with Canadians they're either the
coolest or the lamest yeah Tom McDonald
there's nothing in between
Canadian
ex I got to say he's a douchebag but I
dig the [__] out of his Shades man those
Vuittons his Shades yeah the shades huh
they got like vuon the print on the
lenses Von yeah
Louis Vuitton yeah what Vuitton vuon
Vuitton is that do people ever called
them thaton Von I've never heard that
before
vones he said
it here comes Ben like like 8
miles to save his life mom spaghetti
dude this is like high school level of
yeah talent show Ben is really Ben when
we'll get there but it it really
reminded me of Jake
Paul's um every day every day every day
bro yeah like the the delivery the
[Music]
Rhythm do you see how he awkwardly waves
he's like hi hi it's me
I'm so confused by this guy's Persona
cuz like he obviously the way that he
carries himself and expresses himself to
the world he's very much a part of like
what he thinks is the hip-hop Community
aesthetically like he's gone all out got
the grill
dread you know he's trying to do
something but he also he wants to be on
like the Jesus side yeah I don't do drug
he's rapping about he doesn't do drugs
Ain't No Way premarital sex for real
wasn't there a line about that why do
you look like that he said something
about we won't turn your sons in into
thugs or your daughters into
[Music]
hoes was that the
demon are fat homie I'm epic don't be a
WAP dog it's a y homie no cap look at
the graphs look at my charts you're
blowing
strippers kind of good what was it a dog
it's a yamaka homie No
Cap okay did you hear homie I'm epic
don't be a WAP yeah that I don't
understand he said he's epic he's
doubling down on the I don't like wet
ass p word let's look at the stats I've
got the facts my money like lizo my
pockets are fat that's a true brag he's
rich
homie I'm epic that's a little corny
homie I'm epic don't be a whap a wet ass
[__] mhm dog my yamaka homie no cap
look at the graph look at my charts
you're blowing money on strippers and
cars you're going to prison I'm on
television you're not no one knows who
you are why Ben you are not you're a
YouTuber who do you think is this person
he's like addressing here
I don't know like yeah Ethan his
haters I don't know I yeah like a group
of like Angry like white uh BLM
supporters I don't know or like BLM
blueh haired that that's what they
imagine right they're like also Rich
they're spending money on strippers and
cars that that they are definitely not
that's a confusion of very confusing who
is this person this is not good point no
they're not doing that for sure
mhm get aill number one okay so that
part right there is probably one of the
corniest
lamest that's so um um everyday bro
right all my people download this let's
get a billboard number
one that I that I can't abide by yeah I
love that he's trying to do this uh
Eminem thing with his outfit but he
looks more like ET when they're trying
to hide him put him in a big oversized
hoodie right you could tell it this is
his first time wearing it I just the way
it's creased and stuff I feel like it
just was folded up no steamer on set
right come on now come on look at myart
you're blowing stpp ands prison I'm
Onision dog no one knows who you are
hating on me on the internet my comment
section W and make racks off compound
interest y'all live with your parents
Nikki Tak some notes I just did this for
fun all my people download this let's
get a billboard number one unable
billboard number one that that's just
unforgivable
Disney you you come
on that's the end of the B
pushing we won't turn your sons into
thugs or your daughters in the ho I
don't care if
I I
was
[Music]
yeah again like he loves these people
like Ben Shapiro if Ben Shapiro saw this
guy in the street he would mad judge him
he cross the street yeah well most
people would probably but but like
you're you want to be a part of the crew
but you want to dress and look like the
people that you're making fun of and but
again the people you're trying to be
friends with would judge you hard if
they ever saw you on the street so I
just don't get
it grift it's a grift it's a
cringe it's a major cringe you need to
make a a response to this track if I
offend
you
sorry I abended you I love how they're
always like with the offense like sorry
you triggered like we're still on the
whole that whole wave of like I'm sorry
I'm so offensive M yeah also I'm going
to wrap about how I don't do drugs and I
don't go to strip bars like wow by the
way hoes we don't like hoes around here
right wow you're such a you're so
counterculture man sool m
[Music]
hand is
locked what was that shot what was that
shot why did they include that was that
like supposed to be like
flirty look at that it was like a Herman
can thing yeah exactly coming up
[Music]
this I think so why did they do that I
think it's yeah I think it's a like um
sexy he's trying to Riz you he's Rising
right there sorry if I rised
you here I'll do it in slow
motion here he is Feast your eyes ladies
and men whoever
[Music]
anyone your booty did I do
that oh [__] this is a crispy
4K wow
Gorge let's see of your booty hole thank
[Music]
you I guess it's cool to be the victim
well I'mma be the man you sad you you
you just try to get being triggered all
have said it they said the word you
blame everybody for
every who are you talking you made a
whole song about whatever this is so who
mad this is between you and your
therapist I don't know what's going on
here oh my this is this is childhood tra
bad oh chat gbt wrote me a
[Music]
response so here's my comeback with Flo
Divine challenging Ben airo line by line
I'll bring the truth and Rhythm and
rhyme win back my sponsors it's just a
matter of time so listen up sponsors if
you're out there still I've got more to
say got a void the fill with Beats and
bars I'll climb that Hill cuz losing you
man it's been real [__] bars not the
best that's wasn't that didn't really
stick the ending there also was like
just about me losing
sponsor I said
right right WR a this track about bench
airo making me lose my sponsors ah oh I
guess they he kind of missed the mark a
little bit missed the mark on that one
good flow though that was a 3.5 I could
tell yeah for sure all
right say I'm sorry I ain't taking
nothing back I don't care if I offend
you you haven't really said anything
offens in the
[Music]
song his whole song is like to his
parents no I'm cool like I don't care if
I offend you I'm not taking it back like
no I'm good it's fine it's
yeah maybe take the song back I mean
that's more for him than anyone else
though right you got to unpublish this
quick genuinely who's listening to this
yeah cuz I know anyone that actually
cares about hip hop would never [__]
put this dude it's got to be mostly
People Like Us that are think it's funny
no there's no way he's getting that many
views like look at this [__] 30 there's
no way do you think there are Ben
shipiro kids out there that would enjoy
I find it hard to believe if somebody
liked this type of music they would
listen to like actual talented hip-hop
artists and not this so that's why I'm
thinking it's got to be like weird magga
country guys who are like I like hip hop
when it's not about drugs and hoes yeah
this this kind of hip-hop ain't bad I
could listen to this
one
yeeha okay let's go to his most popular
million fake woke let's what the
comments are 38
million here's some of his merder hi I'm
the toxic male that the snowlakes warned
you about oh [__] me holy [__] dude that
shirt will get you so much
ass holy
[__] very cool so let me read some of
the comments
here feelings aren't facts it's one of
the most valuable things I learned in
therapy
what I just just discovered your song
today and holy Sweet Moses my guy I'm
actually a loss for words at how
accurate relevant and brutally honest
and outright creative you are you are
living proof that the rap genre is not
only still alive it's thriving no drug
glorification no promiscuity no gross
lyrics no fat stacks of money just
honest to God truth with insanely dope
Melodies well
said
yeah there are people out there there
enjoy this I Karate Girl 999 knows hip
hop dude I feel like it's just all
Russian Bots trying to like ruin America
I'm convinced though right that would
make more
sense uh somebody in the chat said my ex
love the [__] it was awful so there's
some real fans out there I
guess all right how long we've been
going uh three and a half we're right on
time my Spidey senses are tangling
exactly
do we should we read some more donos
real
quick uh real quick thank you everybody
so much for the
uh the members and the Don appreciate
that everything you already
read
uh somebody Julia donated 10 bucks and
said for more sketches you guys kill me
there will be more sketches that's part
of why we shifted the schedule around
with uh see you next Thursday um because
Tuesday is a better day for us to all
get together and shoot stuff for the
show so uh theoretically that will uh
continue um for the indefinite future
here I'm glad to have the uh day it's
not punch time now yeah cam cam needs
more time to work as magic on our job by
the way yeah great job hey great job on
writing it Ian hey great job yeah it's
all good all around director Ian uh
thank you for reading my comment now
it's on the record so my friends can't
steal it oh I think that was one of the
name suggestions earlier also naming my
kid Mud so please read so it's on the
res record you're naming your kid Mud
big Primus fan dude My Name Is Mud what
is this call me I'm a fan of H3 Tom and
Ben oh this guy oh this person says
she's a fan of H3 Tom and Ben what wow
each one of you has good content that I
enjoy watching wow you're unicorn W that
is a unicorn you are like you have
transcended you are like huh a person of
the people man holy
smokes uh oh Bruce Teddy Sunny BTS BTS
BTS be careful they said they're warning
you why why because Theodore and sunny
because that's a lot to live up to
that's a lot to live up I'm not trying
to live up to them Dan I'm just paying
homage homage homage uh uh Miranda
donated $10 and gave a long list of baby
name suggestions um too late I'm sorry
the name has been locked in I'll read
them off just to read them off Jasper
Ros Jasper
Jasper you want to submit that one now L
Jasper uh Rosco Perry Percy these are
all very good like kind of old old names
mhm Percy Franklin Leo Fletcher Oscar
Archer kind of like Archer Samson Gideon
Vincent and Donovan donov Donovan's a
nice one some good suggestions in there
Donnie uh they will not be used though
because the kid's name is check this out
me waking up my mom at 3:00 a.m. because
I threw
up it's good it's a factom no cap look
at the look at my charts you're blowing
money on strippers and cars you going to
prison I'm on television no one knows
are by the way amongst hasic Jews
apparently prostitution is a huge
problem I've heard in Israel so really
just saying huh is that what the tunnels
were for that's what the tunnels were
for yeah yeah apparently uh I I've
watched a documentary I've heard from
people that the prostitutes say that
heds are like a ton of their
clientele well also because you're not
allow to be gay so there's I think yeah
you know okay a lot of stuff going
underground interesting that's probably
true um here's an important one $50
donation from Sicilia the people of
Hawaii would see throwing or even
dipping a Stanley Cup in their volcano
as a huge sign of disrespect of their
land and culture I live on kwaii and I
just wanted to state with peace in love
so you guys don't get canceled LOL love
you guys that was why I was kind of
hesitant when we were talking about it
cuz I I know that there's stuff around
that that the tour guy gave us the
thumbs up sounds like Iceland well
that's Iceland might be the way to go
which I'm not complaining about a trip
to Iceland i' go I'd go to Iceland well
go to Iceland for this Iceland might be
cheaper for me cuz you probably won't
want to stay there as long I mean it's
Eternal Darkness right now it's true and
it's freezing that's true it's probably
very [__] cold I've always wanted to
go though
so what's the tempature just saying
what's the what's their big town there
raik raik Iceland weather report M it's
probably not too you don't think so well
it's probably the middle of the night
there right now it's got to be freezing
that be pretty cool it's currently minus
two swing minus two Celsius 28 degrees F
I went in June and around that time you
have a pretty like normal Daytime
Nighttime so on these so just in
Fahrenheit I'll I'll say the high the
highest high of the week is
29 me you talking that's fine it is it's
like yor below freezing I was just in
Idaho and it was that cold so it's not
too extreme Iceland is not that far
north so it won't it won't be too dark
on the winter what the hell are you
talking about it's not like I'm looking
at pretty [__] North it's comparison
to Sweden it's like you're going to have
a a decent
hour like night okay all right all right
you you are fromion so hold on hold on
hold on let me look at world map CU
that's confusing to
me I mean it's about halfway up in
Latitude from I guess there's places in
Sweden that are
higher it's up there it's getting up
there my city where do you live in the
North no just just at the level with
Iceland pretty much like mid a little
bit further down yeah interesting
okay well then you would know if you
want to you should go to swalberg if you
want pure
nberg the Norway Island up there yeah
yeah I'll pass on that one do people
live there yeah mostly researchers
though yeah that there's civilians
living there too fallard wow
um all right we should uh we should wrap
it up it's getting late thank you
everybody it's been fun it's been great
and uh shout out to Jason who is the
proud recipient of uh
five galaxies two watermelons and seven
uh GG's
hearts and
um um that's about it thank you everyone
for your support thank you to all our
members thank you to everyone who's
watching it's all
appreciated and I hope you all have a
great weekend
and um we'll see you guys on Monday so T
have a good
weekend
could instead you're
close